Das Rasenfunk-Tribünengespräch.
Ja klar war es ein besonderes Gefühl, ein riesen Erlebnis, er ist Bundesligaspieler, das ist klar, aber Fußballspiel ist immer das Gleiche und deswegen war es eigentlich trotzdem ein normales Spiel.
Weil er einfach Fähigkeiten hat, die momentan ein Innenverteidiger benötigt. Das sind die modernen Spielmacher, die den Ball in die Tiefe spielen, die sicher am Ball sein müssen, die ruhig sind, die kopfballstark sind, die keine Probleme haben, unter Druck einen gescheiten Ball nach vorne zu spielen und das beherrscht er.
Ich hab die Ruhe weg, Badstuber!
Ein Thema und jede Menge Nachspielzeit. Holger, Ich hab die Ruhe weg, Badstuber ist Gast hier im Tribünengespräch Nummer 38. Hallo Holger Badstuber, schön, dass du dabei bist.
Servus zusammen, vielen Dank, dass ich hier sein darf.
Ja, schön, dass wir dich hier in deinem Schloss besuchen können. Ich hab gerade schon Witze über die Akustik gemacht. Nein, ein Schloss ist es nicht ganz. Aber du hast schon ein bisschen Podcast-Erfahrung im Sinne, dass du auch Podcasts mal hörst hin und wieder.
Exakt, weil es mich interessiert und da man ja häufig auf der Straße ist oder auf Auswärtsspielen ist, wo man genügend Zeit hat, mal andere Dinge zu hören, höre ich gerne mal in Podcasts rein. Und von dem her finde ich es einfach auch mal sehr interessant und cool, selbst an einem Teil zu nehmen.
Ja, ich bin gespannt, was du dann in ein paar Stunden drüber sagst, wenn wir fertig sind, ob du dann noch der unaufgeregte Badstuhl bist. Weißt du zufällig, wie sich der Rasenfunk finanziert?
Nein, du musst mir auf dem Springen helfen.
Wir sind werbesponsoren und paywall-frei. Wir finanzieren uns allein über Spenden der Hörerinnen und Hörer. Alles, was du hier siehst, ist gespendet und mein Lebensunterhalt. In diesem Zuge danke ich nämlich Dennis Robacho, Stefan Felix Kress, Markus Wolf, Franzen Flechter, Delange und Nies aus Münster. Die alle sind nämlich Spender. Ein paar davon nenne ich immer am Anfang jeder Folge. Ich würde mit dir gerne über die Position des Innenverteidigers sprechen. Ich denke, wir müssen auch ein bisschen über die Position des Linksverteidigers sprechen und wie sie sich verändert hat mit Blick auf deine Karriere. Ich habe mich jetzt sehr lange nicht nur mit deiner Person befasst, sondern auch generell mit der taktischen Position des Innenverteidigers. Gibt es denn eine undankbarere Aufgabe im Fußball eigentlich?
Im Fußball? Klar, undankbar ist es in manchen Situationen. Dennoch ist es einfach eine spannende Position, die sich über die Jahre auch völlig verändert hat. Früher gab es ja noch den Vorstopper oder die Libero, etc. die eigentlich für die Ballgewinne oder für das Aufbauspiel zuständig waren. Heute sind es die Innenverteidiger, die einfach sehr, sehr viel am Ball sind, die das Offensivspiel mit vorbereiten müssen. Das hat sich schon sehr gewandelt, die letzten zehn, 15 Jahre, würde ich sagen. Und dann hat sich auch der Typus der Innenverteidiger geändert und verändert. Ich bin Teil davon und habe die Zeit miterlebt. Ich bin jetzt zehn Jahre dabei und es hat sich schon auch da etwas verändert.
Aber undankbar ist es doch geblieben, oder? Man fällt nur auf, wenn man Fehler macht. Wenn man etwas gut macht, wird es im Zweifel nicht gesehen. Und die Stürmer werden für ihre Tore gefeiert.
Ja, das ist schon immer der Fall, dass die Offensiven natürlich für Spektakel sorgen, für Furore und dahingehend ist auch für den Zuschauer natürlich die Tore, die erzielt werden, häufiger vom Stürmen oder von den Offensiven. Und daher sind die vielleicht mehr im Fokus. Aber dennoch bin ich total happy, dass ich diese Produktion einnehmen darf. Da muss man damit leben, das weiß man von vornherein. Aber schönste ist immer, wenn man eigentlich nichts von einem hört, weil dann hat man eigentlich seine Sache gemacht.
Ich meine, dass du damit fein sein musst, wie der Innenverteidiger betrachtet, wird ja klar. Die Frage, die ich mir gestellt habe, ist, ist es bei Innenverteidigern schwieriger, für Journalistinnen und Journalisten ihre Leistung zu bewerten? Weil Tore, die Stürme werden an Toren gemessen, Mittelfeldspieler an der Anzahl der gewonnenen Dribblings an Passquoten und solchen Dingen. Und ich habe das Gefühl, Innenverteidiger, vor allem, wenn man jetzt weiter zurückgeht, inzwischen gibt es ja Statistiken zu vielen Positionen, aber es ist gar nicht so leicht, die Leistung von einem Innenverteidiger in einem Spiel zu bewerten.
Gut, ich komme nicht von dieser Sicht der Dinge. Ich glaube, es ist nicht so einfach, weil die Innenverteidiger, klar, das letzte Glied der Kette oft sind vor einer Riesentorschau des Gegners, vor einem Abschluss etc. wo man dann natürlich immer viel Schuld dem Abwehrspieler geben kann oder auch gewisse Kritik äußern kann. Sicherlich ist es dann auch der Fall, dass man auch mal genauer hinschauen muss, welche Löcher er davor stopft oder was er auffangen muss. Zweikämpfe natürlich auch, aber das wird ja heute schon auch gesehen und analysiert. Aber sicherlich ist es schon für den Journalisten und den Außenstehenden zum Teil schwieriger, die Leistung des Verteidigers und Innenverteidigers zu bewerten.
Und worüber freut man sich dann in einem Spiel als Innenverteidiger? Ist es denn die spektakuläre Grätsche? Es gibt Trainer wie zum Beispiel Guardiola, die sagen, wenn du grätschen musst, das ist eigentlich das letzte Mittel, das möchte man ja eigentlich vermeiden. Was ist jetzt dein persönliches Erfolgserlebnis in einem Spiel?
Gewonne Zweikämpfe oder Kopfballduelle. Natürlich gehört auch Tore dazu, weil dadurch spielt man sich immer wieder schon in Fokus. Wenn ein Abwehrspieler mal ein Tor macht, dann ist das schon auch seltener. Und dann stellt sich das schon mehr in Fokus. Aber für mich sind es wirklich die Zweikämpfe, schwierige Situationen, zwei gegen eins, wenn der Gegner mal auf dich zukommt und du löst das gut. Beziehungsweise ist der Gegner dann auch nicht so gut, weil wenn zwei gegen eins kommt, muss eigentlich schon, wenn das gut macht, eine Torschuss rausspringen für den Gegner. Aber da kannst du natürlich dann trotzdem gut aussehen. Wenn du dann dich da rein haust, dann auch Emotionalität oder Emotionen zeigst. Das bringt auch das Publikum auf und von den Rängen. Von dem her kannst du dann auch das Spiel ein bisschen beeinflussen durch solche Situationen. Deine Gegner ein bisschen schwächen bzw. deine Mitspieler pushen, dass du da bist, dass du der Fels der Brandung bist, dass da keiner vorbeikommt und du nichts zulässt. Die Defensive entscheidet eben Meisterschaften. Die wichtigen Titel kommt man über die Defensive. Das ist ein geschriebenes Gesetz und das hat es jetzt auch über die Jahre, Jahrzehnte bewiesen.
Du kannst ein gutes Plädoyer für deine Position halten, das überrascht mich jetzt aber nicht wirklich nach so vielen Jahren. Jetzt kommt aber ja niemand auf die Welt und wird als Innenverteidiger geboren, zumindest aktuell noch nicht. Wie bist du denn zum Fußball gekommen und dann ja später auch zu der Position?
Durch den Fußball, durch meine ganze Familie, mein Vater, Fußballtrainer, die ganzen Brüder meines Vaters, Fußball, also durch und durch Sportlerfamilie und da kommt man schnell in Kontakt mit dem Ball und dann bin ich schnell zum Fußball gekommen mit vier Jahren, mit fünf Jahren, sechs Jahren dann im Verein gespielt und dann hat sich das so entwickelt. Parallel habe ich dann noch ein bisschen Tennis angefangen, wo es dann wirklich auch professioneller wurde und ich dann auch mit zehn Jahren zum VfB Stuttgart gewechselt bin, dann habe ich mich entschieden, das war dann einfach Fußball und da habe ich die größte Freude gespürt, die meiste Durchschlagskraft gehabt und auch das Durchschlussvermögen gehabt, um mich da einfach auch voranzubringen.
Und was fasziniert dich am Fußball? Ich meine, jetzt verdienst du ja dein Geld damit, jetzt ist es auch ein Beruf, aber gerade in den jungen Jahren braucht es ja was, was einen dahin zieht und was einen ja auch fernhält von all den anderen Dingen, die man mit seiner Zeit empfangen könnte.
Erstens mal das Gruppengefüge. Man ist tagtäglich unter Leuten, unter Mitspielern. Das Soziale kommt natürlich dann auch mitten ins Boot, weil man sich auch natürlich korrekt verhalten muss gegenüber Mitspielern, Trainern. Man lernt schnell über die sozialen Pflichten auch und so weiter nachzudenken. Und man ist eben kein Einzelkämpfer und Einzelsportler, sondern man gewinnt im Team mit letzten Endes und man verliert im Team. Und über die Jahre schätzt man dann schon vor allen Dingen, was es ausmacht, wenn ein Team funktioniert. Und wenn da wirklich auch eine Homogenität ist, wenn da eine Dynamik ins Rollen kommt, wenn da so eine innere Vertrautheit herrscht, dann kannst du wirklich Großes bewirken. Und nicht nur das Team, die 11 auf dem Platz stehen, sondern wenn das gesamte Team plus Staff, aber auch zum Teil auch noch der Verein, wenn die wirklich den Gedanken und sich Gedanken verbündeln, dann kann wirklich Großes entstehen. Und das durfte ich auch erleben, von dem her weiß ich, von wann ich rede, dass das auch dann ausschlaggebend sein kann für die letzten paar Prozent, wenn es dann wirklich um die Wursche geht. Und das ist für mich schon das Schönste gewesen, warum ich dann auch Fußball begonnen habe. Klar, um mich zu verwirklichen, meine Leidenschaft nachzugehen, zu beißen, mich zu verbessern, das Spiel zu lernen, mit Köpfchen zu spielen. Das sind alles die Dinge. Aber auch vor allem in der Gruppe zu agieren und tagtäglich mit Jungs zusammen zu sein und mit denen Spaß zu haben und gerade auch in der Kabine zu sein, das sind Momente, die man dann auch nicht vergisst.
Das hört sich ganz schön abgeklärt an, ehrlich gesagt. Wann würdest du denn sagen, hat das bei dir angefangen, dass du über Fußball nicht mehr nur als Spiel nachgedacht hast? Weil als Kind ist es ja einfach nur ein Ball, den will man hinterherrennen, den will man schießen, das ist geil. Wann würdest du sagen, du bist schon so früh zum VfB Stuttgart gewechselt, dann wenig später, also ab 2002 dann schon bei dem Ball, das war dann im Alter von 13 Jahren. War das dann auch so der Wechsel, wo du angefangen hast, dann so über Fußball nachzudenken?
Ja, dann war dann schon klar, parallel zur Schule, die man sich dann auch vom Elternhaus natürlich auch beenden muss, oder gut beenden sollte, aber da war dann schon die Richtung vorgegeben, wo ich sage, okay, wir wollen schon in die Richtung gehen und mal schauen, wohin es reicht und dafür tun wir alles. Das Elternhaus und ich natürlich auch, die nehmen viel auf mich und verzichten auf vieles, aber da hat sich dann schon mal das dann so hingehend auch in den Gedanken entwickelt, dass ich sage, okay, jetzt bin ich bei Bayern München und da musst du dich durchsetzen, weil das ist einfach der größte Verein in Deutschland. Und wenn du da irgendwann mal oben trainieren darfst und mithalten kannst, das wäre ein großer Traum und der Traum, der ist immer in Gedanken. Und wenn man den dann verwirklicht, dann hat sich das alles gelohnt. Aber wie gesagt, da musste ja auch viel drauf verzichten und man muss viel opfern. Dennoch war das schon dann so eine gewisse Richtung für mich einfach persönlich, wo ich sage, okay, jetzt bin ich beim größten Verein und ich habe tolle Trainer, ich habe gute Mitspieler, die mich jeden Tag fördern. Jetzt liegt es auch an mir.
In dem Alter schon, schon mit 13, 14 oder?
Man sagt ja immer, das Bayern-Genis kriegst du schon eingeimpft, weil du immer als der große Favorit da bist und jeder will dich scheitern sehen. Aber vom Club aus ist natürlich dieses Gewinndrang immer da. Du bist beim größten deutschen Verein, beim erfolgreichsten auf der ganzen Welt. Also du musst gewinnen, steht außer Frage.
Macht es denn dann überhaupt noch Spaß?
Natürlich, wenn man dann möglich mal gewinnt, dann ist es schon wie eine Art Droge. Gewinnen ist einfach das Schönste. Und dann, wie gesagt, solche Momente danach zu erleben mit der Mannschaft, die in Erinnerung bleiben. Dennoch ist Gewinnen einfach, ob es Training ist, ob es Trainingspielchen sind, wo es dann auch zur Sache geht. Das ist schon etwas, was jeder wollte. Und wo ich dann auch oben angelangt bin bei den Profis, da spürst du das bei jedem Spieler. Speziell, der auch dann aus der Jugend raus ist. Und die Großen, die dann dazugekommen sind, bei denen spürst du es einfach. Diese unbändige Wille zu gewinnen und verlieren, das ist keine Alternative.
Ich habe mal nachgeguckt von Rot an der Rot, das ist bei Memming, da wo du geboren bist, nach München sind es anderthalb Stunden einfache Fahrt. Wie habt ihr denn das damals gemacht?
Ja, wie gesagt, das habe ich ja vorher gesagt, das Elternhaus oder mein Elternhaus, Mama und Papa, meistens Mama ist dann gefahren, weil mein Vater selber im Sport unterwegs war, ein Trainer war. Und dann ist meine Mama die Strecke viermal mindestens die Woche gefahren. Und das sage ich auch mit Opfern, dass meine Eltern viel geopfert haben, auch meine Vester. Das bleibt mir in Gedanken und das schätze ich ungeheim. Und das ist auch nicht alle Tage, weil ich hätte auch mit dem Zug fahren können. Aber sie haben mich gefahren und da sind viele Kilometer und viele Autos draufgegangen. Wie gesagt, ich konnte es zum Glück zurückzahlen in irgendeiner Art und Weise, weil ich auch der Allerstöpfe getan habe. Und wie gesagt, da bin ich sehr dankbar dafür. Und das steht außer Frage, dass ich mich da auch immer wieder revanchiere.
Das darfst du auch für dich behalten, auf welche Art und Weise. Aber wie unterscheiden sich denn jetzt die Anforderungen von deinem Amateur-Club, in dem du gespielt hast, und dann eben Jugendabteilung VfB Stuttgart und dann Jugendabteilung FC Bayern jetzt aus Spielersicht? Was hat sich da verändert?
Ja, die Mitspieler werden besser, du wirst mehr gefordert. Du musst dich verbessern, du musst dich weiterentwickeln, du musst einen Ehrgangsentwickeln, weil sonst bleibst du auf der Strecke, schon ein kleiner Alter. Und ja, dann musst du dich auch in Turnieren und so weiter beweisen. Und dann wird ja schlussendlich auch immer aussortiert. Und wenn du die Hürden immer weitergehst, dann hast du immer mehr Chancen, auch wirklich im Profibereich dann Fuß zu fassen und dann auch eine Karriere irgendwie einzuschlagen. Ich war eher so einer, der sich vielleicht ein bisschen später rauskristallisiert hat, dass da was werden könnte, weil ich auch vom körperlichen Her ein bisschen hinten dran war. Dadurch war es für mich aber gut, weil ich musste viel mehr spielerisch lösen. Weil körperlich konnte ich zum Teil nicht so wirklich dagegenhalten, weil sich das dann eher später entwickelt hat. Also musste ich andere Lösungen finden. Das heißt ja auch, ich muss mitdenken, ich muss schnell sein, in Gedanken vor allen Dingen. Und es kommen auch wieder schwächere Phasen dazu, aber auch da muss man durchgehen. Und dann musst du natürlich auch Leute haben, die an dich glauben letztendlich und dir dann eine Chance geben, die dich fördern, die dich auch anpacken richtig. Und das war bei mir der Fall. Und trotzdem habe ich es dann letztendlich durchgezogen und geschafft. Weil, wenn sie das erkennt hätten, die werdigen Trainer, dass ich es nicht schätze, dass ich nicht alles dafür tue, dann hätte ich auch keine Chance gehabt.
Einer der Trainer war ja dann Hermann Gerland bei den Bayern Amateuren. Da sind wir dann jetzt so in der Saison 2007, 2008. Der hat dich auf die 6 gestellt.
Weil wir zu dem Zeitpunkt auch zwei gute Innenverteidiger hatten. Erfahrene, also das war das erste Jahr Amateure, war auch noch für mich ein wichtiger Spieler. Thomas Linke und Christian Saba, zwei Erfahrene, die hinter mir gespielt haben, die mir viel beigebracht haben, von denen ich viel abschauen konnte, die mich auch an die Hand genommen haben. Gerade Thomas Linke, bei Bayern habe ich auch viel mit Ex-Spielern gesprochen, die sagen, dass er auch mit der beste Verteidigerin, die es bei Bayern gab, war. Das konnte ich dann auch erleben und sehen und zu schätzen gelernt. Genau, der Mann Gerland hat mich dann auf die Sechs gestellt, um Fußballspiel zu lernen, um Situationen zu lösen, Männer im Rücken zu haben, in die Zweikämpfe zu kommen. Auch mir diese Härte zu verleihen, was es einfach im Männerfußball braucht, um dagegen zu halten, um weiterzukommen und letztendlich auch die Mannschaft weiterzubringen, Erfolg zu haben, aber auch sich selber zu fördern. Da hat er mir schon die Chance gegeben und auch das richtige Auge bewiesen, mich da auf die Position zu stellen, die ich dann auch knapp zwei Jahre ausgeführt habe.
Aber es ist ja schon im ersten Moment stressiger, auf der Sechs zu spielen, oder? Weil man hat Gegner, die von allen Seiten kommen können. Man hat zwar auch in allen Seiten die Möglichkeit, eine Situation aufzulösen, aber das heißt, man muss sich halt eine sehr gute Vororientierung haben. Wie ist denn da der Unterschied zur Innenverteidigung?
Als Innenverteidiger weißt du natürlich, dass du eigentlich hinter dir keinen mehr hast. Und als Sechser bist du natürlich im Spiel eingebunden. Du musst verlagern, du musst die Dinge lösen, du musst Löcher stopfen, du musst läuferisch dabei sein. Das sind dir viele Parallelen geboten. Und damals in unserer Mannschaft war das eben die Position, die vor der Abwehr stand, aufgefangen hat, was geht, antizipiert hat, ein sauberes Passspiel hatte, verlagern konnte, vielleicht auch mal ein Tor machen konnte. Aber wir hatten damals eine gut funktionierende Mannschaft und das hat mir natürlich auch geholfen, dass ich mich da auch weiterentwickeln konnte und zu einer Stabilität auch meinerseits, aber auch für die Mannschaft geführt habe.
Aber hast dich nie weiter nach vorne ins Feld gezogen?
Nein, ich habe mich eher weiter zurückgezogen von der Jugend. Jugend war ich eher weiter vorne, war ich ein bisschen auf den Außen oder auf der Zehen. Aber auch durch meine körperliche Entwicklung hat sich das dann auch ein bisschen dazu geführt, dass ich einfach ganz gut auf die Sechs passt, spätestens als Innenverteidiger von der Konstitution her. Und das hat sich dann so entwickelt und ich fand das voll in Ordnung. Ich habe da Riesenspaß drauf gehabt. Und als Hermann Gellheim zu mir sagte, du wirst später mal Innenverteidiger, dann dachte ich so, nee, sehe ich mich ja eigentlich nicht so, ich bin nur Sechser. Aber er hatte da das richtige Auge und die richtige Weitsicht. Und es ist so gekommen. Ich habe dann das erste Mal bei den Amateuren Innenverteidiger gespielt, aber eher wenn einer gesperrt war oder sowas. Das erste Mal als Innenverteidiger habe ich mich wirklich bei den Profis gesehen.
Da kommen wir gleich noch dazu. Ich wollte noch kurz mit dir über den Kader sprechen. Du hast schon Linke genannt, der da gespielt hat, Willi Sagnol, auch Valérien Ismael haben immer wieder Spiele gemacht in beiden Amateuren, aber auch viele junge Spieler, also Thomas Kraft, Georg Niederbayer, Toni Kroos, Mehmet Ekece, Thomas Müller, Sandro Wagner. Wie muss ich mir denn das Gefüge in so einer Amateur-Mannschaft, die ja wild durchgemischt ist aus erfahrenen Profis und eben Jungen, die genau dahin wollen, wo die Erfahrenen gerade herkommen? Wie muss ich mir da die Dynamik vorstellen?
Ja, dass die mit denen sich erfahrenen natürlich schon das Sagen haben. Aber sich natürlich auch darauf einlassen will, wenn die beiden Amateuren spielen und vielleicht da ihre Karriere dem Ende zugeht, dann wissen die genau, was wichtig ist, wie es funktioniert und wie sie auch auftreten, um uns weiterzubringen und natürlich auch Respekt zu bekommen. Und das haben die perfekt gemacht, ob es Christian Saba war oder, wie gesagt, auch speziell Thomas Linke, der uns immens geholfen hat. Da hat sich das dann so einfach gefügt aus talentierten Jungen, die natürlich noch viel lernen müssen, aber engagiert sind, und dann diese Alten, die sie führen, von denen man lernen kann und die auch das Wort innerhalb der Mannschaft hatten. Und das war schon so diese alte Schule, aber es war sehr gut. Und wir haben zwei gute Saisons gespielt. Die Jahre danach ist es eher sukzessive abgegangen. Aber wir haben damals, gerade speziell mein zweites Jahr bei den Amateuren, eine super Saisons gespielt.
Was war da anders im zweiten Jahr? War das anders als das erste Jahr?
Wir waren vielleicht schon mehr zusammengewachsen, auch selber ein bisschen erfahrener. Da war einfach Qualität vorhanden, wo man wusste, da werden es nicht nur ein, zwei schaffen, sondern allgemein in der Bundesliga wird man häufiger von solchen Namen hören. Da haben wir einfach eine ordentliche Saison gespielt, wo der fünfte Platz am Schluss rauskam in der dritten Liga. Vor uns waren Vereine wie Union Berlin, Düsseldorf, also das sind heutzutage Bundesligisten. Braunschweig, ich weiß nicht, ob die vor uns waren. Die dritte Liga war damals schon eine starke Liga. Das war dann schon für uns einfach ein riesen Erfolg und ein Genugtum, dass wir gute Jungs sind und dass wir weiter am Ball bleiben müssen. Aber unsere Zukunft könnte gut aussehen.
Das hast du schon angesprochen, das war damals ein durchaus interessantes Konkurrenzfeld in der dritten Liga. Wie groß war dann trotzdem noch der Sprung in die erste Mannschaft? Hast du damals, 2008, 2009, da schon mit trainiert? Das war dann unter Jürgen Glinsmann mit Lucio Demichelis von Beuthen.
Unter Jürgen Glinsmann habe ich ab und zu mit trainiert, wenn man mal einen Spieler braucht, der von der zweiten oder Ersatztraining auffüllen musste. Jupp Heynckes, der die letzten vier oder fünf Wochen übernommen hat, hat mich fest dazu genommen, zum Training jeden Tag, aber auch zu den Spielen, wo ich mitgereist bin. Ein 19. Mann war, also ich durfte einfach mal reinschnuppern in die ganze Sache und hat dann auch schon ein bisschen ab und zu mal so Kommentare abgelassen, wo ich dann gemerkt habe, er sieht immer was. Auch Jupp Heynckes, ein großer, großer Trainer, sieht immer was. Wo man sich dann schon insgeheim darüber gefreut hat, dass so einer auch überhaupt einem auffällt oder dass ich ihm überhaupt auffalle. Und er mich sieht und auch es mir sagt. Das war dann schon schön. Aber dass dann die folgende Saison dann so läuft, das habe ich mir erträumt. Aber ehrlich gesagt, war ich einfach nur froh, dass ich dabei war. Und dann hat sich die natürlich rasant entwickelt.
Genau, da wollte ich gleich noch hinkommen. Lass aber noch kurz bei der Saison bleiben. Also Lúcio de Mequeles und Van Beuthen waren damals so die, die damals Stamm waren in der Innenverteidigung. Wie funktioniert denn das dann in so einem Training? Hat man als jemand, der quasi aus der eigenen Jugend hochkommt, dann viel in den Trainingsformen mit denen zu tun? Kann sich von denen was abschauen oder spielst du dann oft gegen die, weil quasi Mannschaft A gegen Mannschaft B irgendwie das Abschlussspiel machst und dann kannst du quasi nur so über den Platz gucken, wie die hinten verteidigen? Wie war das?
Ja, das war mein erstes Mal aus der Trainer-Mathematik. War das schon immer ein bisschen aufregend? Natürlich, wir waren eine große Mannschaft, die dann auch in dem Jahr, also im zweiten Jahr nicht mehr, der Jahr davor waren sie Meister, in dem Jahr, die finde ich, viel ist auch schief. Aber es waren trotzdem gestandene, große Spieler. Und mit denen dann zu trainieren, war erst einmal einfach schön. Man konnte es genießen, man konnte so viel abschauen im Hinblick darauf, was sie alles geleistet haben, für welche Nation sie spielen, was sie für Titel haben und aber auch welche Eigengewächse eben schon dort Bestandteil waren, fester Bestandteil. Und zu der Zeit waren es eben auch viele. Und dann hat man schon auch die Hoffnung gehabt, eines Tages einfach da auch Bestandteil zu sein und wirklich auch seinen Weg da zu gehen. Man konnte viel abschauen, jeden Training, Dinge beobachten, wenn man sich halt auch gewissermaßen auch verhält.
Was sprichst du da dann von so etwas wie Stellungsspiel, Zweikampfführung? Was sind da so die Dinge, die...
Ja, erstmal reinhängen, natürlich keine Blöde zeigen, seine Qualität auch zeigen. Ja, natürlich, Respekt muss man immer zeigen. Gerade, das war sehr wichtig, weil dann merken sie auch, ok, du bist ein guter Junge, da nimmt der ein oder andere dich vielleicht auch mal an die Hand und quatscht mit dir, was natürlich auch, wo man nur profitieren davon kann. Aber gerade solche Sachen, sonst muss man sich einfach reinhängen und sich beweisen, klar. Und nicht zurückstecken und alles raushauen, was geht. Aber auch zuhören. Und jedes Training, wo ich da mit trainieren durfte, war wirklich sehr spannend und aufregend. Man konnte so viel abschauen, das waren tolle Momente. Und dann im Jahr darauf war das einfach der Fall, dass ich dann fester Bestandteil war und voll am Start war. Und dann war das so rasant, dass man das so gar nicht beschreiben kann, wie schnell man dann wirklich integriert war in die ganze Gruppe. Und auch zum Teil ja schon dann wirklich da überhaupt keine Diskussion mehr war, dass man gespielt hat.
Das war dann die Entwicklung in der nächsten Saison. Und Jürgen Klinsmann, warst du noch bei zwei Spielen im Kader, die eher so in ungute Erinnerungen geblieben sind. 1 zu 5 in Wolfsburg und das 0 zu 4 in Barcelona. Will man da denn überhaupt eingewechselt werden bei Spielen, bei denen die eigene Verteidigung so hergenommen wird?
Ja, zu der Zeit war mir eigentlich klar, dass ich jetzt nicht reinkomme. Da muss schon so viel passieren, dass er mich jetzt da in das ein oder andere Spiel reinwirft.
Wobei, in Barcelona gab es ja durchaus ein paar Verletzungsprobleme.
Ja, schon, aber trotzdem, da hätten noch weitere Folgen müssen, dass ich da irgendwie gestanden wäre. Das waren meine ersten zwei Spiele, in denen ich wirklich auf der Bank war. Da hat man schon gesehen, dass irgendwas am Argen ist. Auch in dieser Saison, in der Wolfsburg Meister wurde, blieb Bayern einfach den Erwartungen zurück. In Wolfsburg hat das legendäre 5-1. Da habe ich mal mitbekommen, wie die Stimmung danach ist und wie die Empfindungen danach sind. Das war schon sehr bitter. Dann ist man einfach nur ruhig.
Das kann ich mir vorstellen, dass man da nicht die Klappe aufmacht. Dass Barcelona Bayern mit 4 zu 0 besiegt hat, das war ja das legendäre Barca unter Pep Guardiola, das dann gegen Manchester United das Champions-League-Finale gewonnen hat. Jetzt im Nachhinein nicken alle, so wie du es gerade gemacht hast, als du gesagt hast, das ist das legendäre Barcelona. War dir das damals auch schon klar, als du diese Mannschaft gesehen hast, ja dann auch aus nächster Nähe, dass diese Mannschaft und dieser Stil den Fußball schon ganz schön verändern könnten?
Ja, die waren damals so dominant, es war so impulsiv. Und es war so extrem zu sehen, wie die den Gegner beherrscht haben. Da waren erstens große, große Spieler und zweitens hatte alles Sinn. Jeder Pass hatte Sinn, die Spieler Riesenqualität. Das war damals ein 4-0, das hätte aber deutlich höher ausgehen können. Das war damals, ja, mir nur gar nicht so bewusst, was dann daraus entsteht. Was auch der Fußball dadurch natürlich sehr profitieren würde und sich verändern würde, durch diese Mannschaft, muss man schon ganz klar sagen. Damals war es für mich einfach faszinierend zu sehen, wie schnell es geht. Jeder Pass war genau, jeder Pass war mit Sinn und Verstand. Und die Verbindung zwischen den Spielern war zu sehen. Und deswegen haben die dann auch solche Phasen oder solche Jahre auch untereinander hingelegt, weil man sehen konnte, wie da alles einfach passt.
Damals haben Piquet und Puyol in der Innenverteidigung gespielt. Waren das dann auch damals Spieler, an denen du dich orientiert hast? Wer waren so die Spielervorbilder für dich in der Zeit?
Ja, ich fand natürlich, war da Piquet so der aufstrebende junge Bursche neben dem erfahrenen Puyol, der aber speziell zu Peps Stil sehr, sehr gut passt. Puyol kommt eher über das Körperliche, über die Präsenz, das Fußballerische. Ja, ist er gut, aber nicht das gewesen, wo ich mich jetzt auch nach orientiert habe. Puyol ist ein Riesenspieler, ist halt mit anderen Dingen zur Legende geworden, als mit fußballerischer Extra-Klasse, muss man ganz klar sagen, aber er war ein Leader. Also man hört ja immer wieder, dass er – viele sagen – ihr bester Kapitän war und so weiter. Aber ich habe mich damals – klar, junger, aufstrebender Piquet – orientiert man sich dann eher dran, weil er ja erst geschafft hat. Er wurde bei Manchester praktisch weggeschickt so ungefähr und hat es dann bei Pep oder davor auch schon geschafft. Aber damals hat er einfach nochmal einen Riesensprung gemacht. Und das war so der neue Innenverteidiger, wo sich dann auch alle drum gerissen haben und gesagt haben, der versteht das neue Spiel oder das, was man vom heutigen Innenverteidiger einfach sehen will. Ich habe mich da eher auch an meine Mitspieler gehalten. Michio Demicheles, der auch eine starke Saison davor hatte, war für mich einfach auch vom fußballerischen Her, weil er auch oft als Sex war, öfters mal bei Magath, unter Magath-Zeiten. Da konnte ich viel von ihm abschauen. Erster Kontakt und welche Dinge er sieht, viel auch durch seine Erfahrung gemacht, Cleverness. Ich habe mich eher an ihn orientiert, weil ich ihn jeden Tag erlebt habe und sehen konnte, wie er trainiert. Und wie gesagt, er hatte eine starke Phase zu der Zeit. Deswegen habe ich mich dann eher an solche Spiele orientiert, weil ich sie auch tagtäglich erleben konnte. Anstatt welche zu sagen, das ist mein Spieler, den ich entweder im Fernsehen sehe oder mal bei einem Spiel beobachten kann. Ich will immer wissen, was dahinter alles steckt und die tagtägliche Arbeit einfach sehen und auch sehen, was das ausmacht. Und das war für mich dann schon eher so ein Mitchell, den ich dann genauestens beobachtet habe.
Den hattest du dann auch einfach vor der Nase. Ich weiß nicht, ob du zufällig den Film Take the Ball, Pass the Ball gesehen hast. Das ist eine Dokumentation über Barca. Da wird ja nochmal schön nachgestellt, wie Pep Guardiola vor allem erstmal dem eigenen Torhüter und den Innenverteidigern beigebracht hat, ihr steht links und rechts vom Strafraum und wir geben die komplette Mitte frei, was damals totaler Wahnsinn war. Heutzutage haben wir uns da alle dran gewöhnt. Hattest du denn damals den Gedanken, ich würde auch gerne so spielen? Weil es kommt ja auch gewissen Fähigkeiten, die du hast, eben Spieleröffnung, präzises Passspiel, auch einen guten Überblick, wo Räume sind ja entgegen.
Muss ich ehrlich gestehen, zu der Zeit noch gar nicht. Weil Barcelona war für mich noch so weit weg, ich musste erst mal Fuß fassen bei Bayern München. Und da hieß es dann einfach mal Leistung bringen, egal wie, in welchem System, in welchen Zusammenstellungen du musst dich zeigen und du musst mithalten können. Darum ging es. Es ging jetzt noch nicht so, wie ich mich später sehe, wie ich mir Gedanken über den Fußball mache, das war alles noch zu früh. Ich war damals 20, 21. Da will man einfach nur abliefern, sich stetig verbessern, viel abschauen und natürlich auch sich irgendwann Respekt verschaffen, dass du ein vollwertiges Mitglied des inneren Kreises bist von der Mannschaft. Das geht nur über Leistung. Es geht nicht über Reden, über irgendwelche anderen Dinge, sondern es geht über Leistung, wo dann auch die erfahrenen Boobies wie Frank, Arjen, Marc van Bommel, also die schon echt viel erlebt hatten zu der Zeit, die ja dann sagen, eher schützen, sondern dich dann auch zum Teil schützen, weil sie sagen, der Junge, der ist gut der Junge. Aber wir sind diejenigen, die oft die Fresse bekommen oder die Kritik abhaben, also quasi vor der Öffentlichkeit schützen. Ja, auch das, aber auch so intern. Ich habe einfach gespürt, gerade Marc oder Basti oder Arjen, die haben mich akzeptiert. Und Thomas auch. Wir wurden akzeptiert, weil sie gemerkt haben, er ist ein guter Jungs, die wollen hart an sich arbeiten. Da sieht man Potenzial. Die können hier wirklich Fuß fassen und was reißen. Den vertrauen wir und wir sehen, dass wir ihnen vollsten Respekt geben für das, was sie bisher geleistet haben und was sie für Persönlichkeiten sind. Dann führen wir sie auch gerne durch das ganze Business und auch durch gewisse Spiele. Das habe ich einfach gespürt und das ist einfach ein echt schönes Gefühl gewesen. Diese Vertrautheit, aber auch dieses Respektvolle, dass sie sagen, die sind gute Jungs. Das war für mich eines der schönsten Gefühle, die ich anfangs in meiner Karriere hatte.
Da sind wir jetzt wahrscheinlich schon in der Saison 2009, 2010 unter Louis van Gaal. Wann würdest du denn sagen, war dieser Punkt, wo du diesen Respekt innerhalb der Mannschaft hattest?
Ich habe das erste Spiel gegen Hoffenheim gemacht. Das hat sich dann so entwickelt. Ich habe dann schon auch durchblicken lassen, dass ich etwas kann. Sie haben mich tagtäglich im Training erlebt. Louis van Gaal ist natürlich ein großer Förderer für mich, ein toller Trainer. Er hat mich dann ins kalte Wasser geschmissen, aber mit dem Inneren vertraut, dass es sich ausbezahlt. So hat sich das dann so entwickelt. Das war sehr rasant. Wir hatten viele Spiele am Anfang. Ich kann mich dann noch erinnern an mein erstes Champions-League-Spiel daheim gegen Juve. Juve, Weltmeister drin, abgezockte Spiele, italienischer Fußball. Die wissen, wie der Hase läuft. Das war für mich ein erstes internationales Kräftemessen, wo ich sagen könnte, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, wo ich so stehe, wo ich mich auch sehe. Da habe ich meine Leistung gebracht. Durch die Leistung gibt es dann sukzessive, dass man das Vertrauen von den Mitspielern spürt. Die Kommentare, die dir auch auffallen, wenn sie dich in der Presse loben. Damals ist es einfach alles neu und man kriegt alles mit, man saugt alles auf. Der Trainer nimmt dich immer wieder zur Hand und sagt, was schlecht ist. Das musste ich auch erfahren, gerade in meiner ersten Saison. Louis van Gaal hat mich öfters in unserem Auditorium in der Nachbereitung der Spiele herangenommen. Das war nicht immer schön, aber er hat gemerkt, erstens kann ich dem etwas mitgeben, der akzeptiert das, der versucht es dann besser zu machen und anzunehmen, die Situation. Aber ich bringe ihn immer wieder. Er hat mir immer wieder Vertrauen gegeben, zu spielen. Ich habe dann, glaube ich, in dem Jahr mit die meisten Einsätze gehabt. Weiß nicht nach, Philipp, die zweitmeisten.
49 Spiele waren es in der Saison.
Genau, und dann kommt er noch zu, es waren über 50 Spiele in diesem Jahr, was für den Körper komplett neu war. Für den Kopf vor allen Dingen. Der Körper macht das mit 20, mit 21, wenn du fit bist. Aber für den Kopf ist es so viel Neues gewesen, gerade dann noch die zwei Titel, der Champions League Finale, dann noch zu WM. Das war so viel für mich, das alles dann auch zu verarbeiten und einfach auch nicht zu viel drüber nachzudenken, dass ich wirklich dann auch ein bisschen Zeit gebraucht habe, damit klarzukommen.
Da werden wir jetzt auch noch ein bisschen Zeit brauchen, das zu besprechen. So schnell kann ich dich jetzt aus der Saison nicht rauslassen. Ich stelle mir schon die Vorbereitung irgendwie komisch vor, jetzt aus deiner Sicht. Da kommt Louis van Gaal, ganz eigener Trainer. Ihr fangt an zu trainieren. Irgendwann kommen dann die Spieler, die ein bisschen länger Pause hatten, und er sagt zu Basti Schweinsteiger, wer sind sie eigentlich? Und er sagt zu mir, Miróklose, ich habe sie noch nie gesehen, wer sind sie? Wollen sie sich mal ordentlich vorstellen? Und dann geht die Vorbereitung dahin und irgendwann wechselt Lucio und du spielst im ersten Spiel. Was ist denn in diesen magischen Wochen passiert? Erklär mir mal, wie war dein Kontakt mit Louis van Gaal und wie muss ich mir diese Vorbereitung vorstellen? Von außen wurde da mit der Lupe draufgeguckt. Ich weiß noch, im ersten öffentlichen Training wurde genau aufgeschrieben im Artikel, nach wie vielen Minuten der erste Anpfiff von Louis van Gaal an einen Spieler ging. Wie hast du es denn erlebt?
Erste Begegnung mit Louis van Gaal. Er ist ja schon eine Autorität und groß. Er steht sich vor mich, ca. 5 cm, sehr nah am mich ran und sagt, ich bin Louis van Gaal. Wer sind Sie? Da sage ich, Holger Badstuber. Ich habe viel von ihm gehört. Das war es. So, und dann hat es begonnen. Ich war dabei, habe alles versucht umzusetzen, was er wollte. Es war auch eine neue Trainingsform oder Trainingsgestaltung, Trainingssteuerung. Es war sehr, sehr viel Neues. Nicht nur für mich, sondern für alle. Er hat da schon etwas ganz Neues reingebracht. Damals waren die Chips noch neu und so weiter.
Also, dass man quasi getrackt wurde, wie viel man läuft.
Genau, das war alles sehr, sehr neu, aber sehr, sehr professionell. Für mich nach wie vor auch heute noch mit die beste Trainingssteuerung, die ich hier hatte. Wir waren fit. Wir waren fit und wir haben die richtigen Trainingsanheiten gemacht. Er hatte das Gefühl, aber er hatte auch seine Leute an der Seite, die ihn da beraten haben. Und da muss ich sagen, das war top gestaltet, die Trainingssteuerung. Ja, und dann hat sich das so entwickelt. Ich war am ersten Vorderseil, als wir immer noch einen Pokal spielten, da war ich auf der Bank. Und dann hat sich, glaube ich, Mitchell auch ein bisschen wehgetan. Und dann war ich schubsi, wo es war, ich drin. Da war ich nicht mehr von Beuten drin gegen Hoffenheim, damals eine sehr gute Mannschaft. Mit Ibicevic, Carlo Situado, Obasi, Demba Bar, Salihovic, Gustavo. Also es war damals die Wilden, die die großen Mannschaften aufmischen sollten. Das Jahr davor waren sie auch schon zur Winterpause. An erster Stelle sind sie dann abgerutscht, aber mit Hoffenheim war es einfach gefährlich. Das war dann mein erstes Spiel, 1-1 ist ausgegangen. Aber es war schon für mich auch noch live am Start zu sein gegen wirklich starke Spieler.
Und was war der Moment, wo du wusstest, dass du spielen wirst? Im Nachhinein ergibt es auch alles Sinn, weil du warst der einzige Linksfuß in der Verteidigung. Und Louis van Gaal wollte auf der linken Innenverteidigerposition gerne einen Linksfuß haben. Im Nachhinein sieht das total logisch aus und Lucio ist ja auch gegangen. Aber so wird es ja für dich wahrscheinlich nicht gewesen sein. Wann war denn der Moment, wo du das Gefühl hattest, ich könnte hier vielleicht sogar direkt reinrutschen in die Mannschaft?
Ja, wo ich dann mitbekommen habe, dass Mitsu ein Problem hat, glaube ich mit dem Sprunggelenk oder so weiter. Da habe ich schon gedacht, okay, der wird mich reinschmeißen, ist dem wurscht. Also bereite dich darauf vor und sei fokussiert. Du musst da sein, Punkt, du musst liefern. Und das war dann schon auch Eigendruck, aber ich versuchte dann einfach, das zu genießen. Und jetzt bin ich da, wo ich hinwollte, wo ich viele Jahre lang dafür geschuftet habe, wo ich verzichtet habe, jetzt bin ich bei Bayern München und ich darf das erste Saisonspiel machen. Gegen den guten Gegner. Und er vertraut mir. Also das waren so viele Sachen, die sich über die Jahre, eigentlich die Träume, die sich praktisch bewahrheitet haben, alles jetzt auf den Punkt. Und jetzt musst du aber einfach nur liefern. Also es geht darum, jetzt Leistung zu bringen. Das Ganze Emotionale ein bisschen rauszunehmen. Lass es dir nicht anmerken. Versuch einfach ruhig und sachlich deine Partie zu spielen. Das ist mir zum Glück gelungen, weil dann war ich weiter dabei und in der Startelf. Als dann sukzessive Mitchell zurückgekommen ist, bin ich dann eher nach links rausgewandert. Aber auch dadurch nur, weil ich mich zeigen konnte und der Trainer gesehen hat, okay, es ist schwer jetzt den Jungen rauszunehmen, weil er macht seine Sache gut. Aber ich muss Mitchell reinbringen, weil er hat ein gewisses Standing. Was machen wir jetzt? Wie löse ich die Situation? Dann hat er es so gelöst und mir war es in der Hinsicht wurscht.
Es heißt ja, dass Louis van Gaal sehr detailverliebt ist, auch im Training. Wie äußert sich das dann?
Er hat, glaube ich, bei Bayern allgemein einen neuen Stil entwickelt zu spielen, Sachen zu sehen. Das war für mich natürlich neu, aber auch für alle anderen Spieler. Die Trainingssteuerung, aber auch die Trainingsinhalte. Er hat auf die Kleinigkeiten geachtet. Wie gesagt, dann auch seine Nachbesprechungen. Sie waren schon sehr detailverliebt und jeder hat sein Fußballhorizont erweitern können.
Haben das auch die älteren Spieler so gesehen?
Absolut. Ich glaube schon. So habe ich es empfunden, weil er sehr detailverliebt war und der Erfolg ihm auch recht gegeben hat, warum er so ist und dahinter, dass wir die Dinge richtig machen und gut machen und immer wieder das Prozedere durchgehen. Es waren tolle Trainingsformen, auch die Besprechungen, wie er auch gegen den Ball gewisse Züge besprochen hat und veranlasst hat, das zu machen unterm Spiel. Es war gut und für mich genau reingepasst, ich bin in meine Stärke gekommen bei ihm, weil ich viel am Ball war, ich konnte viele Pässe spielen, ich konnte viele Mitspieler erreichen durch mein Passspiel, weil er genau die Linien oder die Zwischenräume besetzt haben wollte, wo dann Spieler wie Thomas Müller das perfekt gemacht haben, auch Miro konnte das sehr gut. Das waren einfach Spieler mit dieser Qualität, den richtigen Raum zu finden und ich musste dann nur das Timing haben und ihnen einfach einen Ball servieren, damit sie aufdrehen konnten und dann waren schon mal ein paar Spiele ausgespielt von dem Gegner. Und das hat er schon eingeimpft.
Also das Positionsspiel hat er ja letztes Jahr.
Ja, Positionsspiel definitiv. Einfach auch diese Zwischenräume zu besetzen, in die Position zu kommen, gewisse Mechanismen in Gang zu bringen, dass man viel Ballbesitz hat und immer wieder rotiert, um dann letztendlich zu Chancen zu gelangen. Das war neu für viele Spieler, weil es war nicht nur das simple Spielzeit, sondern es waren Vorgaben da und die waren gut, weil sie zum Erfolg gebracht haben.
Wobei es ja da auch eine längere Phase gab, in der der Erfolg noch ausgeblieben ist. Das musste sich alles erst finden. Man kann zum Beispiel in der Biografie über Miroslav Klose von Ronald Rengen lesen, dass Klose da schon durchaus manchmal seine Probleme mit diesen klaren, starren Vorgaben hatte. Dass Louis van Gaal zum Beispiel gesagt hat, der Stürmer muss immer auf den ersten Pfosten gehen. Und sobald Miroslav Klose das einmal im Training nicht gemacht hat, wurde sofort die Trainingsform unterbrochen. Wie waren denn die Vorgaben beim Spiel aus der Abwehr heraus?
Ich denke, bei der Abwehr ist das ein bisschen was anderes, weil wir sind die letzte Linie und wir müssen in erster Linie verteidigen. Er hat natürlich viel gefordert, dass wir unsere Mitspieler in Szene bringen. Aber ich verstehe dann Miro total, weil gerade kreative Spieler oder Spieler in der Offensive frei sein wollen. Die wollen ihrem Instinkt folgen. Die wollen nicht eingeschränkt sein, was muss ich machen, was will der Trainer von mir. Sondern sie wollen einfach frei sein, um sich dann auch auszuleben und kreativ zu sein. Vorne geht es um Kreativität, um Chancen, sich zu erarbeiten durch individuelle Klasse. Da muss ich Miro total recht geben. Das war vielleicht dann auch ein Punkt, wo viele Spieler nach und nach sich mir eingeschränkt fühlten und nicht mehr so frei waren und dann auch vom Kopf her eingeschränkt waren und nicht mehr in ihre Stärke kamen. Ein kreativer Spieler muss Freiheiten haben, um sich zu empfalten. Und dann bringt er dir auch diesen Pass oder diese Aktion, um Spiele zu entscheiden. Bei uns Abwehrspielern war das eher nicht so von Bedeutung, weil wir ein gewisses Spiel spielen mussten. Aber Kompaktheit in der Abwehr ist viel wert und das hat er von uns verlangt. Von daher war das jetzt für uns nicht so wichtig, dass er uns da gewisse oder viele Vorgaben gab.
Und wie wollte er das Spiel aus der Abwehr heraus aufbauen? Gegen den Ball war es sehr kompakt. Bayern hatte ab der Saison wesentlich mehr Ballbesitz. Aber das hat sich dann irgendwann gelöst. Hat sich in der Art und Weise, wie du das Spiel aufbauen musst, was verendest? Standet ihr höher, als es früher der Fall war?
Klar, durch das, dass wir den Ball hatten, wurde der Gegner hinten reingedrückt. Ich wusste, welches Spiel ich erreichen konnte. Die Diagonalbälle waren eher zu vermeiden. Er suchte eher die diagonale Lösung mit einem gewissen Winkel, wo mein Mitspieler dann auch auflösen konnte oder aufdrehen konnte, um zu verlagern. Du musst den Gegner in einem gewissen Raum provozieren, um dann schnell rauszukommen und zu verlagern, um dann die kreativen Spieler in Sehne zu setzen und ihnen einen Raum zu geben, sich zu empfalten. Bei mir war Thomas Müller oder Arjen Robben natürlich so ein Empfänger, wo ich immer wusste, wo sie stehen, den konnte ich blind schlagen, weil ich das Vertrauen in mich hatte, den Ball zu schlagen über 30, 40, 50 Meter. Aber weil ich auch wusste, die stehen da und erwarten den Ball von mir. Und wenn ich nicht spiele, dann irgendwann winken sie mich ab, gerade Arjen. Mit Basti hatte ich dann auch einen, weil die waren ein paar Linien vorne, ein paar Meter vor mir. Mit Basti hatte ich auch oder mit Marc einfach eine gute Verbindung, weil ich ihnen vertraute, sie vertraute mir, wenn ich ihnen einen Ball spiele, dann spiele ich keinen scheiß Ball, sondern ich spiele einen Ball, um ihnen eine Möglichkeit zu geben, aufzudrehen, in ihre Stärke zu kommen. Also ich spiele ihnen keinen Ball, um sie in Bredouille zu bringen oder dass ich das gespielt habe. Das hatte schon den Sinn immer von mir und das haben sie auch verstanden und gespürt.
Und der Sinn, wenn ich kurz unterbreche, dass man lieber diagonal anspielt, liegt da drin, weil dann die Bewegung für den Passempfänger keine so groß ist, um aufzudrehen.
Ja, aber wenn du Druck im Rücken hast und du hast keine Orientierung, du bist frontal zu deinem eigenen Tor, ist es erstens nicht so einfach für gewisse Spieler, wenn sie einen im Rücken haben und zweitens einfach auch für den Konter. Das sind einfach auch Bälle, wo der Gegner drauf lauert. Wenn der Gegner spekuliert oder antizipiert und vorne reinkommt, dann geht es nur nach hinten und das wollte man vermeiden. Von dem her waren immer die diagonalen Bälle bevorzugt von mir auch. Ich wusste, wenn wir da einen Ballverlust haben, dann haben wir genügend Spieler hinter uns oder hinter dem Ball, um den Angriff abzuwüllen.
Wie wichtig war denn für dich in dieser ersten Saison, in der du sofort Wettkampf erprobt warst und sofort viele Spiele gemacht hast, wie wichtig waren da für dich die Trainingsanheiten gegen Spieler? Wenn wir jetzt mal die Offensiven nehmen, du spielst ja dann im Training gegen Ribéry, Robben, Gommis, Thone oder Klose.
Es waren viele verschiedene Spielertypen, die mich total viel gebracht haben. Ich habe es geliebt, weil es für mich einfach nur gut war. Es war nur gut, wenn ein Fehler passiert, aber es war auch Qualität gegenüber. Aber ich habe es geliebt. Mirro Klose war für mich als Stürmer gesehen das Schwierigste.
Warum?
Wenn ich den Ball hatte.
Weil er gut im Dazwischenspritzen war?
Er wusste, was in seinem Rücken vorgeht. Er hat gewisse Passwege für mich zugemacht. Er war aber dann auch aggressiv gegen den Ball. Er war stark und hatte einen gewissen Sinn und Antizipation gehabt, was für mich viel gebracht hat. Ich musste Lösungen finden, sonst habe ich ein Problem. Dann ist ein erfahrener, abgezockter, spritziger, schneller, torgefährlicher Spieler weg. Dadurch hat mir die schwierigste Aufgabe gestellt, gegen den Ball. Mit Ball haben sie alle Qualität gehabt. Tore konnten sie alle spielen. Aber gerade, wenn ich den Ball hatte, war das für mich schon neu. Der steht nicht nur vor mir, sondern bringt einen mit. Der läuft mich über meinen linken Fuß an. Ich muss auf rechts und dann.
Wenn man dann dreimal nacheinander die Situation nicht gelöst hat, kommt dann der eigene Stürmer und sagt, du hättest dich so draus lösen können.
Niro hat mir dann schon geredet und schon auch Hinweise gegeben, weil er eben auch Fußballverstand hat und weiß, was dann auch wichtig ist. Gerade mein erster Kontakt. Er hat gesagt, erster Kontakt muss wichtig sein. Dann hat er normal keine Chance, wenn mein erster Kontakt gut ist in gewissen Situationen. Dann kann er nur faulen bzw. kommt nicht hin. Solche kleinen Dinge machen es dann für mich einfach auch aus. Wenn man die auch annimmt, dann kann man sich schnell aus gewissen Situationen viel besser befreien.
Ja, das glaube ich. Du hast in der Saison 27 Spiele als Innenverteidiger gemacht, aber auch 22 als Linksverteidiger. Ich würde behaupten, das sind zwei sehr unterschiedliche Positionen. Wie kommt man denn da mit der Umstellung zurecht?
Das war neu für mich, muss ich gestehen, weil ich Linksverteidiger noch gar nicht so wirklich auf dem Schirm hatte. Ganz andere Laufwege, du hast eine Linie neben dir.
Genau, du hast nicht den Platz in alle Richtungen.
Du hast den Raum groß links, darum bin ich manchmal auch eher ein bisschen innen gefallen und habe nicht die Linie gesucht, weil ich einen Raum nach links haben wollte. Schon eine andere Position, eine andere läuferische Herausforderung, weil du längere Läufe hast, einfach andere Läufe hast. Das war neu für mich, aber man gewöhnt sich an viele Dinge und auch daran habe ich mich gewöhnt. Für mich war klar, ich bin jetzt nicht derjenige, der die Linie rauf und runterläuft. Das bin ich vom Typus her nicht. Aber ich versuche die Dinge so gut wie möglich zu machen und das weiß ich, dass ich definitiv meine Seite dicht mache. Das ist mal das A und O, weil da will ich, dass da keiner durchkommt und dass ich meine Seite definitiv nicht zulasse. Das ist für mich das erste Kriterium. Nach vorne habe ich erst das Franck Ribéry Formel gehabt. Aber das bevorzugt eigentlich Frank, wo ich wusste, da ist einer Formel, der Weltklasse ist und dem ich schnell den Ball spielen muss, der den Ball haben will, der Lösungen hat. Aber ich will ihn natürlich auch unterstützen, so gut ich kann. Aber ich bin nicht der linke Verteidiger, der rauf und runter marschiert und hinterläuft und hinterläuft, sondern ich bin dann auch einer, der diesen defensiven Gedanken hat und weiß, wenn ein Ballverlust ist, dann darf über meine Seite einfach nichts gehen. Und diese defensiven Gedanken, der war eben bei mir vorrangig.
Genau, das Hinterlaufen war da nicht ganz so häufig, wie man es dann später gesehen hat. In der Saison darauf war er an Diego Contempo als Linksverteidiger und dann irgendwann David Alaba. Der hatte ja sowieso eine besondere Chemie mit Franck Ribéry. Das war eine völlig verrückte Saison. Du hast alle wichtigen Spiele mitgebracht. Das DFB-Pokalfinale gegen Werder und in der Champions League natürlich das 4-1 in Turin in der Gruppenphase, das 2-3 in Florenz, mit dem man weitergekommen ist, das 2-3 in Manchester, mit dem man weitergekommen ist. Und dann natürlich auch das Champions League-Finale gegen Inter. Sind das auch so die Spiele, an die du dich aus dieser Saison erinnerst? Oder was sind von diesem unglaublichen Wust an Eindrücken die Dinge, die bei dir hängen geblieben sind?
Ja, gerade die großen Spiele, gerade so zu Hause Juve, bei Juventus Turin, wo das Spiel, ja, Hopp oder Top, du bist weiter oder du bist raus. Und da bin es so 4-1. Das war schon ein sehr wichtiges Spiel, auch für den Verein.
Gilt im Nachhinein so ein bisschen als die Geburtsstunde der positiven Van Gaal-Geschichte.
Genau, genau, genau. Ja, speziell Champions-League waren alle Spiele ja diese Hymne und das ist schon was Spezielles, diese Atmosphäre, Champions League. Dann natürlich auch, ja, erst immer Dortmund, 5-1 gewonnen. Damals war Werder noch gut, Werder Bremen 3-2 gewonnen. Also das waren schon ein paar Spiele, so Schlüsselspiele auch, wo es eng zuging, wo ein guter Gegner war. Werder war zu der Zeit auch eigentlich Stammgast im europäischen Fußball mit Özil, da waren viele dabei, die dann auch international ihre Karriere noch gemacht haben. Aber dann natürlich im Manchester das 2-3, das 2-1 zu Hause gegen Manchester, wo man in der letzten Minute das Tor macht, gegen wahrscheinlich mit das Beste Manchester, wo es zu der Zeit gab, mit Legenden drin, mit großen Namen. Dann das Halbfinale, das wir eigentlich alle sehr souverän gewonnen haben.
Gegen Lyon mit drei Kopfballtoren, Ivica Olić.
Ja, 1-0 zu Hause, 3-0 auswärts. Das war eigentlich die leichteste Aufgabe in diesen Chaos-Spielen. Und dann das Finale, das im Bernabeu, in einem Fußball-Tempel, rasend perfekt, gegen Inter Mailand, gegen eine abgezockte Truppe mit Namen, die es wissen wollten. Da haben wir dann eben die entscheidende Fehler gemacht, dass wir das Spiel verloren haben.
Milito, zweimal getroffen. Ich weiß noch genau, dass damals vor dem Spiel, vor dem Champions-League-Finale, José Mourinho, der ja immer schon dafür bekannt war, auch gerne mal verbal Druck auf den Gegner auszuüben, vor dem Finale gesagt hat, ich mache mir gar keine Sorgen, ich habe Bayerns Schwachstelle identifiziert, das ist die Innenverteidigung. Das waren Van Beuthen und Demi Kehles in der Form. Und ich weiß auch noch, wie das bei den deutschen Journalisten damals ankam. Im Nachhinein, ob jetzt Zufall oder nicht, sind dann auch genau aus so individuellen Fehlern die Tore entstanden. Hast du noch eine Erinnerung daran? Hat das auch in der Mannschaft für eine Reaktion gesorgt?
Klar, provozieren ist immer dieses Trash-Talk, nennt man es heute ein bisschen so. Hat den Gegner auch zu verunsichern und Mourinho ist da schon Meister drin. Ich habe das damals gar nicht so wirklich mitbekommen, dass es das Ereignis im europäischen Fußball war. Da werden viele Sachen geschrieben und darauf darf man aber keine Rücksicht nehmen.
Denkst du manchmal noch an die Chance von Thomas Müller nach Wiederanpfiff oder an den Schlänzer von ein Robben, den er in der Saison so oft gemacht hat und in dem ein Spiel wurde herausgeholt?
Ja, sicherlich. Die Szenen hatten wir vor sich. Gerade Thomas, kurz nach der Halbzeit, wäre es 1-1 gewesen. Ja, es hat nicht sollen sein. Wir waren auch nicht zwingend genug. Es war nicht so unser Spiel. Da war Inter einfach viel Beibesitz, aber in ungefährlichem Zonen. Ja, wir kamen nicht wirklich voran und dann waren sie eiskalt. Und wir waren einfach abgezockt und erfahren. Auf meiner Seite war Eto und Rechtsverteiger Maicon. Maicon, das war seine Saison. Die hatten eine gewisse Sicherheit untereinander, die wussten, uns wird schwer zuschlagen. Um nachhinein haben die das ausgestrahlt. Wir haben das später dann ausgestrahlt, aber die haben es zu der Zeit besser gemacht. Wir haben an dem Tag nicht das abgerufen, was wir eigentlich hätten spielen können.
Das ist ja eigentlich der Wahnsinn, wenn man sich das noch mal überlegt, dass Bayern damals einen Sieg am Triple vorbeigeschrammt hat, wo wir ja alle wissen, es kam dann später 2013, aber wie selten sowas eigentlich ist. Und das trotz dieser Anfangsprobleme. Louis van Gaal, neuer Trainer, am Anfang lief es auch in der Liga nicht so und dann gab es so ein paar Schlüsselereignisse. Wenn du jetzt im Nachhinein diese Saison bewertest, würdest du sagen, das war ein Umbruch für den ganzen Verein FC Bayern? Absolut. Und was waren da die wichtigsten Elemente? War es das Taktische, war es das Zusammengehörigkeitsgefühl, war es das, dass eben junge Spieler nachgerückt sind in den Kader? Was waren da die Elemente?
Viele Elemente, welche aus eigener Jugend geschafft haben, das neue Stil, das uns zugutekommt und der dann auch Erfolg gebracht hat, Bayern München repräsentiert. Davor waren sie immer so, ja, vor den Jahren waren sie immer der FC Hollywood etc. Aber zu der Zeit haben wir uns Respekt verschafft und die Leute haben angefangen, uns zu mögen, die jetzt die Bayern-Hasser waren oder die Anti-Bayern-Fans.
Woran hast du das gemerkt?
Ja, an unserem Auftreten, an unserer Ausstrahlung, dann, wie gesagt, an gewissen Nationalspielern. Es waren viele deutsche Nationalspieler dabei, die auch Deutschen repräsentiert haben. Es waren viele Elemente, die das dann zusammengebracht haben, dass da einfach schon eine Ära begonnen hat, die sich dann weiterentwickelt hat. Eine Mannschaft, eine gewisse Anzahl von Spielern, die über einen langen Zeitraum zusammengespielt hat, die sich kennengelernt haben, privat, die sich gutgetan haben auf dem Platz, die Erfahrungen gesammelt haben, die Niederlagen zusammen erfahren mussten. Dann hat sich so eine Stärke daraus entwickelt, über die Jahre hinweg. Der Höhepunkt war dann das Triple, aber da waren zwei Niederlagen im Champions-League Finale, da waren einfach auch Schmerz verbunden damit, um dann wirklich die Kraft daraus zu ziehen. Und dann natürlich auch die Erfahrung daraus zu ziehen, was man anders machen muss, um es zusammenzuschaffen.
Also wäre das Triple in der Saison ein bisschen Zufall gewesen, nicht unverdient, aber eher Zufall.
Ja, das Triple 2013 war verdient.
Das war einfach verdient. Und dann ist ja das Jahr immer noch nicht vorbei, sondern jetzt kommt ja noch die WM. Eine Woche nach dem Champions-League-Finale debütierst du in der Nationalmannschaft und wenige Tage später dann auch ein ganzes Spiel als Linksverteidiger gegen Bossien. Und auf einmal stehst du im WM-Auftaktspiel gegen Australien in Südafrika auf dem Rasen. Das ging ja auch wieder alles sehr schnell. Ja, das stimmt.
Da war ich einfach dabei. Ich bin ja zu dem Vorbereitungstrainingslager in Österreich oder in die Berge gefahren. Da war ich einfach drin. Aber ich war sehr überrascht, dass ich jetzt da dabei sein darf. Ja, und dass ich dann letztendlich auch am Auftaktspieler der WM links verteidigen würde. Es war einfach alles sehr, sehr viel. Auch nach dieser Niederlage, da hat man eigentlich schon einen Urlaub gebucht und dann wird man angerufen, du komm mal wieder mit ins Trainingslager. Ich dachte, ja gut, vielleicht werde ich dann, der wird sich jetzt nicht mal anschauen. Aber da sind jetzt zu viele Erfahrer dabei, die schon lange in der Nationalmannschaft sind. Das ist die Elite des deutschen Fußballs. Du darfst da dabei sein. Was für eine Rolle du spielen wirst, wird man sehen. Aber erwarte nicht zu viel. Zu der Zeit behalte ich auch schon meine 50 Spiele in den Knochen. Das war dann auch für den Kopf etwas Neues. Jetzt kommt noch eine WM. Eine Turnierform ist auch noch mal etwas anders im Nachhinein. Das ist auch noch mal lange aufeinander hocken, immer im Hotel sein. Das war dann auch speziell für den Kopf eine Herausforderung, die die notwendigen Körner dann auch rauszuholen.
Waren denn dann die Anforderungen an dich als Linksverteidiger in der Nationalmannschaft andere als beim FC Bayern?
Nein, nein, nein. Wir hatten damals natürlich auch – da wurde dann der deutsche Fußball wieder gefeiert, weil wir da gut abgeschnitten hatten, weil wir frech waren, weil wir diese frische, an den Tag legenden, schnell umzuschalten. Damals war nicht der Ballbesitzer in der deutschen Nationalmannschaft so vorrangig, wie Bayern-Spieler haben das so ein bisschen reingebracht vielleicht. Aber es war eher das Kompakte, das Disziplinierte, was die Deutschen auch ausmacht. Und dann nach vorne mit viel Kraft und Wucht, sich Chancen zu kreieren und dann auch schnell zum Abschluss zu kommen. Das haben wir in dem Turnier sehr, sehr gut umgesetzt. Dann, wie gesagt, auch mit einer gewissen Frechheit. Gerade Thomas Müller wurde ja dann auch jüngster Torschützler. Den hatten einfach viele noch nicht so wirklich auf dem Zettel, obwohl er ja auch schon das Jahr bei Bayern auf dem Buckel hatte. Aber da hat einfach auch alles oder viel gestimmt. Das ist dann nicht der große Wurf, aber das hat halt auch noch die Jahre gebraucht, um dann wirklich den großen Traum wahr werden zu lassen. Aber da hat auch bei der Nationalmannschaft fast begonnen.
Und es gab vorher die Wade der Nationen, Michael Ballack, der verletzt wurde, von Kevin-Prince Boateng vor dem Turnier. Das war so ein bisschen das beherrschende Thema davor. Hat das für dich dann eine Rolle gespielt, weil du warst ja ganz neu in der Mannschaft?
Ja, hat überhaupt keine Rolle, weil ich war ja nie dabei davor. Also ich hatte keine Verbindung zu der Personalien Michael Ballack. Ich habe ihn im Nachhinein natürlich kennengelernt. Aber zu der Zeit war das das vorrangige Thema. Wie wird Deutschland ohne den Kapitän abschneiden?
Ja, aber das war für mich keine Bedeutung. Wie unterscheidet sich denn ein Training von der Nationalmannschaft zum Verein? Ich stelle es mir schwieriger vor, in der Nationalmannschaft Automatismen einzustudieren. Das ist jetzt eine Sonderstation, weil du bist gleich ins Trainingslager mitgekommen. Das ist die einzige Zeit, wo man über einen längeren Zeitraum mehr Trainingseinheiten hat.
Ja, das ist natürlich sehr komprimiert, und da muss man schnell den Spielern erklären, was man sehen will, aber ich konnte mich gut anpassen und das war kein Problem für mich, die Vorgaben des Bundeslagers damals umzusetzen und mich da zu integrieren. Das war kein Problem, und die deutsche Nationalmannschaft hatte damals schon einen gewissen Plan, und da waren auch die Spieletypen dabei, die auch darauf gepasst haben.
Du hast dann gegen Australien im ersten Spiel gespielt und dann im zweiten Spiel gegen Milos Krasic. Das war dann eine schwierige Reparatie, und da wurde dann unter anderem auch du in der Öffentlichkeit kritisiert. Die restlichen Spiele hat dann Jerome Boateng auf der Position gemacht. Geht die Öffentlichkeit in der Nationalmannschaft während einer WM deiner Meinung nach anders, mit schlechten Situationen um? Ist der Druck da ein anderer nochmals beim FC Bayern?
Nicht unbedingt, aber klar, das war halt eine WM. Wenn man da Einzelne nochmals verloren hat gegen Serbien mit dem verschossenen Elfmeter, dann wäre es wieder nicht so schlimm gewesen. Aber es hat dann auch alles gepasst. Ich war aber auch vom Kopf her nicht mehr so frisch, und die Leistung war dann nicht gut, aber nicht so, wie es dann vielleicht auch nach außen gemacht wurde.
Aber ist da eine andere Hysterie da, wenn Deutschland verliert?
Ja, sicherlich. Gerade auch gegen Serbien, als eigentlich der Underdog war, und man sollte da eigentlich schon den Gruppen-Siegs ungefähr klarmachen oder das weiterkommen. Das war dann schon auch neu für mich, weil ich das Jahr drüber noch nicht so diese Kritik bekommen hatte. Aber ich habe dann versucht weiterzumachen und Gas zu geben im Training. Ich war trotzdem der Neuling in der ganzen Truppe.
Es hilft ja bestimmt auch, wenn man in Südafrika ganz schön weit weg ist von den großen Teilen.
Ja, aber da kriegt man einfach auch viel mit. Ich meine, als junger Spieler nimmst du das dann schon nochmal anders wahr, als wenn du das jetzt schon immer öfters gehabt hast. Und gerade für mich war es einfach so ein bisschen das erste Mal, das zu erleben und dann auch Kritik von der deutschen Presse abzubekommen. War nicht so einfach, aber man entwickelt nachher auch weiter und man lernt dazu. Und letzten Endes haben wir ein gutes Turnier gespielt und ich war Teil dessen. Und das war eine schöne Erfahrung, auch wenn es für mich dann so einen kleinen Beigeschmack hatte.
Hätte Deutschland im Halbfinale gegen Spanien gewonnen, wenn Thomas Müller nicht gesperrt gewesen wäre? So hat es Urs Siegenthaler nach dem Turnier gesagt.
Damals war Spanien einfach eine starke Mannschaft. Hat nicht sollen sein. Wir hatten auch nicht wirklich Chancen in dem Spiel. Da war Spanien schon dominanter und in den wichtigen Situationen einfach besser.
Kann man das dann auch direkt nach dem Abpfiff schon so akzeptieren, dass man sagt, so ähnlich wie er beim Champions-League-Finale auch, es war heute einfach nicht unser Tag und die anderen waren stark? Oder wie lange braucht das?
Ich war nicht auf dem Platz, aber es braucht dann schon ein bisschen. Man weiß genau als Fußballspieler, welche Situation man hätte anders lösen müssen oder was Ausschlag geben war für die Niedlage. Das weiß man eigentlich relativ schnell, weil gewisse Mechanismen dann noch immer wiedergreifen. Aber man hat so – ja, die Enttäuschung ist dann trotzdem da. Also es ist ein Halbfinale, WM und du bist kurz vor der Finale. Und das ist einfach enttäuschend, wenn du dann da mit einem 1-0 rausgehst. Und egal, ob es verdient ist oder nicht, aber das ist einfach enttäuschend, weil das ist einfach eine große Chance, die kommt nicht so oft.
Du hast jetzt vorhin gesagt, dass die Nationalmannschaft damals ja noch keinen Ballbesitzfußball gespielt hat und nach vorne mit viel Wucht. Da hatte ich direkt ein Tor im Kopf, nämlich das Tor von Miroslav Klose nach langen Abschlag von Neuer, wo er einfach nur einen Zweikampf gewinnt und also einfach nur ein Wünschungszeichen. Ist das Tor dann repräsentativer für die Nationalmannschaft damals als zum Beispiel das Tor von Arne Friedrich gegen Argentinien, wo man sich mit schönen Kombinationen durchkombiniert und am Ende dann einen Doppelpass gespielt wird?
Also das war schon – nee, also gerade gegen Argentinien war, finde ich, genau so die Tore so ein bisschen, die für uns gestanden haben. Das war so das Spiel, kompakt hinten stehen mit Argentinien war offensiv sehr, sehr stark besetzt, da einfach enge Räume zu bieten und dann schnell nach vorne umzuschalten. Weil wir wussten um die, vielleicht die Umschaltschwäche der Argentinier, wo man sie dann auch überraschen konnte, wenn es schnell abgeht, wenn wir schnell ins Tempo kommen, wenn wir Räume reisen und wenn wir dann schnell in die Box kommen. Und so waren dann, ich glaube, das Spiel war wirklich prädestiniert für uns und das war damals ein sehr, sehr gutes Spiel von uns und das hat eher den deutschen Fußball zu der Zeit wirklich dargestellt. Genau so war das Spiel, das hat perfekt gepasst.
Okay, wenn du jetzt mal den Badstuber von vor der Saison 2009, 2010 mit nach dieser langen Saison 2009, 2010 vergleichst, was hat er dazugelernt?
Viele neue Eindrücke, Erfahrungen, wie man sich in gewissen Situationen verhält, außerhalb des Platzes auf dem Platz der Hunger, man war am Champions-League-Finale, das will man nur mal erreichen, die Titelgier, weil man hat zwei Titel in der Tasche, betritte kann dann eigentlich relativ schnell mit einem Supercup, also das war schon dann schnell entfacht, das war ja um weitere Titel zu sammeln, um anzuknüpfen, das zu bestätigen, jetzt auch fester Bestandteil der Nationalmannschaft zu sein. Man gehört jetzt zu den besten Deutschlands und einfach am Ball zu bleiben, aber trotzdem demütig zu sein und zu sagen, du hast noch nichts erreicht, du willst noch weiter hinaus und veränder dich nicht zu sehr. Verändern tust du dich immer, aber halte deine Werte aufrecht, stehe für das, wie du auch hochgekommen bist, und dann wird sich dein Weg auch weiter positiv bleiben, auch wenn man mal Schwächephasen zukommt oder auch Rückschläge. Aber wenn du dem treu bleibst für das, was du stehst, dann kommst du weiter voran.
Okay, aber das waren jetzt ja alles quasi so Charaktereigenschaften und Einstellungen zu deinem Job. Was hat sich denn fußballerisch bei dir getan in dem Jahr?
Ja gut, ich habe viel gelernt. Ich habe gesagt, durch das tagtägliche Training, durch die Spiele, man ist durch die Erfahrungen, die gewisse Situation zu lösen, was geht im Fußball, wo muss ich mich noch verbessern, wie bereite ich mich auf gewisse Gegenspieler vor. Das hat sich dann schon alles spezialisiert und in mehr ins Detail gegangen. Man musste, wo noch kleine Sachen fehlen, um den nächsten Schritt zu machen, um präsenter zu sein, um weniger Fehler zu machen, um sein Spiel zu verfeinern. Das kommt nach und nach. Dann kommst du wieder in Situationen, wo du es anders löst und sagst, so geht es. Dann sprichst du wieder mit Mitspielern. Darüber. Du hast meine Mentoren, Arjen, Marc van Bommel, zum Teil Miro, Philipp, Basti. Die geben dir dann noch Feedback. Oder wenn du mal nach dem Training in der Kabine sitzt, dann schildern sie ihre Sicht der Dinge, einfach aufsaugen, wie du Dinge noch verbessern kannst. Und neben dem Platz muss man sich um mich keine Sorgen machen. Klar, das war jetzt auch was Neues in der Öffentlichkeit, anders wahrgenommen zu werden und durch München zu gehen. Man wird erkannt und so weiter. Aber ich wusste, dass ich da nie Probleme haben oder das so ausnutzen werde, dass ich den Fokus auf den Fußball verliere.
Und wusstest du auch genau, was deine Schwächen sind, wo du dich verändern musst? Du hast es jetzt schon angedeutet, dass es um Details ging. Aber hast du auch unter anderem von Van Gaal das Feedback bekommen, dass du noch zulegen musst?
Das war eigentlich nicht so. Das hat er eigentlich nie analysiert oder dir mitgeteilt. Das habe ich selber gespürt oder auch selber gewusst, wo ich mich noch verbessern könnte.
Was waren das so? Kannst du da ein Beispiel nennen?
Ja, gerade die körperliche Präsenz. Ich habe damals noch acht Kilo weniger gewungen als heute. Dann aber auch diese Robustheit zu haben in gewissen Situationen. Wenn es wirklich darauf ankommt, gibt es gewisse Zweikämpfe im internationalen Fußballgewicht, die musst du gewinnen, die darfst du einfach nicht verlieren. Das sind entscheidende Szenen, wo dann ein Gegentor entscheidend sein kann und fallen kann. Ich weiß nicht, wie ich das ausdrücken kann, aber es gibt so ein Gefühl, wo du hast, den darf ich nicht verlieren. Und den verlierst du dann auch nicht, wenn du weißt, wie du den angehen musst, und da gibt es kein Zurückziehen. Und das Gefühl kriegst du halt, wenn es dann auch mal scheppert, wenn es dann auch mal falsch geht, dann weißt du, ok, das passiert mir nie mehr. Und die Einsicht musst du auch haben und draus lernen, das ist zum Glück nicht so oft passiert, aber ich habe mir so viele Gedanken über den Fußball nebenan gemacht, sodass ich mich ständig damit beschäftigt habe, was wirklich wichtig ist und welche Situationen wirklich wichtig sind in Phasen des Spiels. Ich habe mir vertraut im Passspiel, ich habe mir vertraut im Kopfballspiel, das ist nicht die Frage, da macht mir keiner was vor. Ich weiß, in welchen Situationen ich den Ball spielen kann, aber gerade jetzt, wenn es eng zugeht oder wenn der Ball in den Rücken geht, werden die Stimme, wenn Fuchsiker, umso besser sie sind und umso höher es geht, ein Vorteil verschaffen und das musst du dann auch wissen, wie du die Sachen löst.
Also kommen dann so ein bisschen die Tricks?
Ja, natürlich. Wie sie dich anlaufen, wie sie in dem Rücken agieren, wie sie mit dem Körper arbeiten. Es sind Kleinigkeiten, wie sie dich vielleicht davor bearbeiten mit dem Körper, wo du einfach auch Stärke zeigen musst oder auch dagegenhalten musst, um halt nicht den entscheidenden Zweikampf zu verlieren. Das hast du dann irgendwann im Gefühl, das ist ganz wichtig, den darfst du nicht verlieren. Das weißt du ja, das sind Millisekunden, aber das weiß man dann einfach.
Aber sowas lernst du ja tatsächlich einfach nur, wenn du diese Spiele spielst.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das jeder Spieler wirklich so Intus hat. Wenn es dann wirklich zum Erfolg kommt und du Champions League Viertelfinale, Halbfinale dann weiterkommst, das sind die Erfolge. Das sind ja dann diese wichtigen Spiele, wo es dann halt ausmacht. Gerade mit den Auswärtstoren und mit den geschossenen Toren. Oder dann halt auch die Titel sammelst, wenn es Endspiel, DFB-Pokal oder über eine Saison hinweg, wenn du dann nach oben stehst in der Meisterschaft. Dann weißt du halt, du hast weniger Fehler, wie der Gegner oder wie die restlichen Tiefkinder macht, um da zu stehen. Man weiß dann halt auch, durch das tagtägliche Training, was du halt immer mit Weltklasse-Spielern zu tun hast, wenn wichtige Situationen im Spiel sind. Welchen Ball du nicht spielen darfst und welchen Kopfball du nicht verlieren darfst und welchen Schritt du nicht machen darfst, sonst bist du weg. Das ist ein Gefühl, das du dann nach und nach rein kriegst und dann auch so eine innere Stärke entwickelst, wo ich dann auch sukzessive entwickelt habe. Gerade 2012, wo wir dann leider der zweiten Plätze hatten, aber da war für mich so eine innere Stärke da, wo ich wusste, boah, ich bin gerade wirklich voll präsent. Ja, das hast du, obwohl wir dann diese Scheiß-Saison hatten mit diesen vielen Enttäuschungen, aber da hat sich das so sukzessive entwickelt.
Okay, dann kommt die Saison 2010, 2011. Contento sollte auf links spielen, hat damals Van Gaal schon früh angekündigt, du bist dann wieder in die Innenverteidigung gerückt. Und es gab ein Ereignis in diesem Jahr, was ich auch aus deiner Sicht als Spieler interessant fand, nämlich den Wechsel von Hans-Jörg Budt zu Thomas Kraft im Tor in der Winterpause zur Rückrunde hin. Hat das denn für dich als Innenverteidiger auch etwas verändert?
Ja, aber das war schon eine Vor- also Jörg Budt hat ja auch eine Champions-League-Finale gehalten.
Genau, aber der Wechsel zu Kraft, das war in der Winterpause.
Ach, zu Kraft, sorry, jetzt.
Oh ja, was verändert das für einen Innenverteidiger, wenn hinter einem ein anderer Torhüter steht?
Ja, für mich war das jetzt nicht so, klar, Louis van Gaal wollte eben einen spielerischen Torhüter auf dem Feld haben und wollte das auch ein bisschen durchboxen, wo wir eigentlich mit Hanns-Jak Bud ein Keyboard drin hatten, der ein gutes Jahr in der sich hatte, der keine Art Fehler machte, wo dann Anlass dafür war, einen Wechsel vorzunehmen, aber der wollte das so ein bisschen durchboxen. Es gab schon auch dann die eine oder andere Diskussion, das hat man schon gemerkt. Man merkt dann schon immer, wenn es ein bisschen brodelt, auch zwischen Präsidium und…
Woran merkt man das dann als Spieler?
Ja, man merkt das dann an den Blicken, wenn man zusammen auch fliegt oder auf Reisen ist. Die werden natürlich auch hinter den Kulissen einige Gespräche geführt haben, aber man merkt so ein bisschen, wenn was in der Luft liegt. Das Gespür hat man dann ein bisschen. Und wenn dann auch noch die Presse das ein bisschen befeuert, dann ist ja eh das präsent. Ja, es war dann auch nicht die Phase, es war ja auch nicht das Jahr, wo wir wirklich gut waren. Weil wir kamen dann aus der WM und viele deutsche Nationalspieler sind spät eingestiegen. Ich hatte nur zweieinhalb Wochen Urlaub. Da kann sich jetzt auch nicht gerade erholen von über 50 Spielen oder 55 Spielen, Summa summarum. Auch mental halt nicht. Und dann in die nächste Saison zu starten. Am Anfang ging es noch, aber ich habe dann gemerkt, so gerade Oktober, November, dass du einfach niemanden in den Körner hast. Weil du keine gescheite Vorbereitung hattest. Ich bin sofort eingestiegen in den Supercup, nach ein paar Tagen. Ich habe vielleicht noch diese Euphorie, diese Selbstverständlichkeit von der WM mitgenommen. Aber sukzessive ist es ein bisschen weniger geworden. Dann blieben die Erfolge aus und dann wurde es ein schwieriges Jahr für uns. Dann kamen eben noch solche Wechsel hinzu und Unruhe war da. Und dann hat man so ein bisschen das Brodeln gespürt, was dann im Verein ist. Auch diese Unsicherheit, wie geht die Saison oder wie verläuft die Saison, wir starten nicht gut, wir verlieren ab oder wir haben zu viel Abstand an dem Champions-League-Teilmann, dem Direkten usw. Das merkst du dann schon. Dann wird der Druck natürlich mehr zu performen. Dann sind wir relativ souverän durch die Gruppenphase Champions-League und dann hört es früher aus gegen Inter-Mailand.
Natürlich.
Und dann gewinnst du bei Inter 1-0 und verlierst zu Hause 3-2. Das ist dann auch bitter gewesen, hat dann irgendwie auch dazu gepasst. Dann hat sich das auch so ein bisschen zu einer echt schwierigen Saison entwickelt, wo viele dann auch nicht ein Maximum an Leistungen bringen konnten.
Und wenn du das jetzt gemerkt hast, im Oktober, November, boah, es ist echt zäh, ich hatte…
Das merkt man dann so, wenn man ein bisschen Gespür dafür hat – ich glaube, die erfahrenen Spieler wussten das noch stärker oder noch mehr wie ich – dass das schon eine zäheste Saison werden kann. Weil dann der Druck kommt, dann werden Entscheidungen getroffen, dann wird es einfach unruhig. Dann kommt die Presse hinzu, die das dann auch noch befeuert. Das dann alles zu stabilisieren, ist nicht so einfach.
Das letzte Spiel von Louis van Gaal war dann auswärts in Nürnberg. Da hat Thomas Kraft einen Rückpass nicht weit nach vorne geschlagen, sondern er hat versucht, den Ball auf Philipp Lahm auf der rechtsverteidiger Position zu spielen. Er war zu kurz und so fiel dann das 1 zu 1. Und ich glaube, zwei, drei Jahre später hat Philipp Lahm dann mal in einem Interview gesagt, ja direkt im Training vor diesem Spiel hat Thomas Kraft den Ball weit nach vorne geschlagen und von Louis van Gaal den Anpfiff bekommen. Nein, du musst das Spiel konstruktiv aufbauen. War das so?
Ja, ich kann mich noch erinnern, dass Louis van Gaal das immer haben wollte, diese Bälle auch auf die Außenverteidiger zu spielen, mit einem gewissen Risiko, mit einer gewissen Schärfe. Aber ja, ich weiß auch noch, dass der Philipp einmal gesagt hat, wenn er den Ball verliert und wenn der Ball nicht gut kommt, dann bringt er sich selber in Bredouille und dann ist es schwierig, weil...
Hatte er das vor van Gaal gesagt?
Ja, ja, im Training mal. Und wie reagiert er dann einfach? Weil Philipp war einfach, hey, Philipp kannst du immer anspielen, aber es war ein Risikoball, der ihn einfach von vorne rein in Bredouille gebracht hat, wo er entweder ins Kopfballduell muss, wo er so gut annehmen muss und so risikoreich annehmen muss. Wenn gut ein Gegenspieler kommt, der das antizipiert, der vielleicht dazwischen spurtet, dann ist es für Philipp einfach schwer in der Situation. Und das war mal auch so eine Diskussion im Training, aber van Gaal hatte da mal mal, war der Sein Mama sturend und sehr rechthaberisch und wollte das einfach durchbringen. Kraft hat das dann gemacht, weil wo es so verlangt, dann mache ich es. Aber im Endeffekt, zum Nachhinein fand ich das von Philipp auch eine Stärke, das zu sagen, dass der Ball schwierig ist. Ich nehme die Verantwortung, aber es bringt mich einfach in gewissen Situationen in Bredouli. Das muss nicht sein, das kann man vermeiden.
Ist das öfter passiert, dass ein Spieler im Training Louis van Gaal gesagt hat, von der Idee bin ich jetzt nicht überzeugt?
Nein, aber es wurden immer wieder neue… also er hat auch mit uns darüber geredet. Während des Trainings hat er viele Situationen angehalten. Dann natürlich gerade Führungsspieler wie Miro, mit Van Bommel, auch Arjen Frank, auch Hammi zu der Zeit. Es waren ja viele Spieler, die auch eine gewisse Meinung hatten und die haben es dann auch schon geäußert. Aber Louis van Gaal war eben auch überzeugt von seiner Sichtweise und blieb es einfach so stehen. Dann hat sich das auch so ein bisschen so entwickelt und man hat es dann auch so ein bisschen in der Stimmung gemerkt, dass dann halt das nicht so auf Dauer so gut angenommen wurde, dass man eigentlich nach einer Meinung fragt, aber im Endeffekt stur bleibt.
Okay, eigentlich die Antwort schon kennt. Das war dann das Ende von Louis van Gaal beim FC Bayern und ich frage da deswegen auch so detailliert nach, weil ich damals zumindest den Eindruck hatte, also im Jahr 2011 und dann noch so die folgenden Jahre, dass das so ein bisschen der letzte Eindruck von van Gaal war, der in München geblieben ist und sich das vielleicht jetzt erst mit neun Jahren Verspätung so ein bisschen dreht. Wie würdest du denn die Bedeutung von Louis van Gaal als Trainer für den FC Bayern bewerten? Jetzt nicht nur für dich.
Große Bedeutung, wie gesagt, vom Spielstil, von dem, dass er eigentlich den Verein sehr, sehr gut repräsentiert hat mit seiner Autorität. Er war, denke ich, schon auch beliebt mit seiner Art und Weise, wie er gesprochen hat, wie er gefeiert hat, wie er analysiert hat.
Wo man das ja erst spät gesehen hat. Also bei Journalisten, glaube ich, war Louis van Gaal nicht komplett beliebt, weil die hat er auch ganz schön in Ruhe angefangen.
Also absolut, absolut. Aber er hat sich mit ihm beschäftigt, er hat es nicht links liegen lassen, er hatte immer eine Meinung und natürlich, wie er sich dann mal kundgetan hat, das ist seine Art und Weise. Aber er hat sich nie ignoriert oder ist an ihm vorbeigelaufen. Ich denke, er ist immer schon ein gestandener Mann und ein absoluter Fachkenner vom Fußball und hat dem FC Bayern sehr, sehr gut getan. Absolut. Und viele Spiele weitergebracht, den Horizont erweitert und alle Spieler, die auch länger bei Bayern geblieben sind, haben von ihm profitiert.
Er hat so Dinge eingeführt, wie dass es eine Nachbesprechung des vergangenen Spiels gab. Hermann Gerland hat dann später mal erzählt, dass er sich an Louis van Gaal orientierend dann auch bei den Spielen der Amateuren auf den Gegner vorbereitet hat. Vorher hat man da eher so, ich zitiere Hermann Gerland, so mir-samir-mäßig einfach gesagt, wir hauen die schon irgendwie weg. Hört sich so ein bisschen an, als hätte Louis van Gaal den FC Bayern in den modernen Fußball reingebracht.
Absolut. Also ich war ja davor nicht dabei, von dem her. Da wollten wir vielleicht modern sein mit Budas etc. wo man da platziert hat oder mit irgendwelchen Techniken. Aber wenn es um das Spiel Fußball geht, absolut.
Und wie war das dann nochmal als Trainer Andres Joncker und vor allem Hermann Gerland zu haben am Ende dieser Saison?
Gut, ich glaube, Andres war sehr beliebt, weil er eine gewisse Ruhe hatte. Er wusste, er kannte uns, er war offen und kommunikativ und hat uns da mittends ins Boot genommen. Das war auch die einzige Chance von ihm, dann auch erfolgreich den Schluss zu gestalten. Und wir wussten natürlich, was auf dem Spiel steht, also wir mussten irgendwie die Champions-Siege erreichen. Und dann sind es glaube ich aus fünf Spielen 13 Punkte geworden. Ja, da war dann schon jedem klar, wir müssen jetzt performen und wir müssen einfach gewinnen. Da steht außer Frage, um dem Verein nicht Geld wegzuwerfen, dass der Verein einfach einplant.
Man will ja selber auch Champions-League spielen.
Ja, natürlich auch, aber es war schon auch gewisse Art und Weise Druck da vom Verein. Der FC Bayern gehört in die Champions League und dem geht viel Geld durch die Lappen. Wenn wir das nicht erreichen und das wollen wir definitiv nicht verantworten, sondern wir wollen dafür verantwortlich sein, dass der FC Bayern Champions-League-Spiel Punkt. Dafür muss man performen und wir wollen auch nächstes Jahr Champions-League spielen, um jeden Willen. Das haben wir dann auch gut hingekriegt.
Warum brauchst du dann für so etwas eine Trainer-Entlassung? Das war ein Knackpunkt in der Saison, dieses Nürnberg-Spiel und das, was danach kam.
Wenn es dann ein bisschen Ungreimtheiten gibt, dann kommt dann eine Gruppendynamik zustande. Ich als junger Spieler habe versucht, mich auf meine Leistung zu fokussieren. Das war auch ein neuer Druck für mich, aber man hat dann einfach auch gespürt, wie die Gruppe sich verändert, gegenüber dem Trainer, dass es nicht mehr diese Überzeugung. Ist, dass er der Trainer ist, der uns jetzt weiter trainiert. Das kommt dann zustande und dann kriegt man auch in der Kabine mit, wenn es dann auch kritische Äußerungen gegenüber dem Trainer gibt, dann wird das auch ein bisschen aufgestachelt und das kommt dann schnell in Gang und dann ist halt letzten Endes der Trainer derjenige, der weichen muss.
Das ist das Geschäft. Ja, das stimmt natürlich. Es kam ja dann zur neuen Saison, Jupp Heynckes. Das ist jetzt die Saison, die du vorhin schon ein bisschen angeteased hast, Saison 2011, 2012. Was hat sich denn mit Jupp Heynckes verändert?
Ja, Jupp Heynckes, allein die Persona von Jupp Heynckes, er kannte den FC Bayern, er ist Verbündeter des FC Bayerns, er ist ein großer, großer Trainer.
Er hat sich nicht fünf Zentimeter vor dich hingestellt und dich verpasst.
Nein, überhaupt nicht. Die größte Stärke oder das Unglaubliche an Jupp Heynckes ist einfach seine Menschenkenntnis bzw. auch, wie er die Spieler behandelt, wie er eine Verbindung zu den Spielern aufbaut, zu jedem einzelnen Draht hat. Das ist einfach, was für Jupp Heynckes in Persona steht. Das ist das, wo er unglaublich gut drin ist, wo er Spieler fangen kann, wo er sie in die Stärke bringt, wo er ihr Vertrauen gibt. Und das hat sich einfach von Beginn an sehr, sehr gut angefühlt. Es war wieder ein Zug drin, es war Spaß drin, es war die Saison abgehakt, die davor passiert ist. Wir müssen uns qualifizieren für die Champions League. Das war damals gegen Zürich, glaube ich. Und dann war es neu ins Gange. Die Gruppe ist schon länger zusammen, die kennen sich alle. Man ist jetzt hungrig, man weiß, wie es sich anfühlt, im Champions League-Finale zu stehen, dann leider zu verlieren. Diese Verbundenheit ist trotzdem da. Und dann gehen wir es an mit einem neuen Trainer, der eine Philosophie hat, der aber eben auch jeden in die Stärke bringt und nicht gerade die kreativen Spiele beschränkt. In gewissen Ansprachen oder Vorgaben, die er vor jedem Spiel gibt. Sondern er bringt sie erstens, wenn sie fit gemacht haben, das muss man auch sagen, Jupp Heynckes, das erste Jahr, das zweite Jahr, wir waren topfit. Die Spieler sind resistent, vertrauen ihren Körper und haben Körner für die ganze Saison, das spüren sie. Und dann bringe ich sie noch in die Stärke. Für Jupp Heynckes war einfach eine Autorität da, für die man alles geben wird. Und das ist etwas Großes, wenn man das hinbekommt.
Du hast jetzt gesagt, ein Trainer, der eine Philosophie hat, wie würdest du denn die Fußballphilosophie von Jupp Heynckes beschreiben? Ist vielleicht der größte Unterschied zu van Gaal, dass er eben in manchen Bereichen, wie zum Beispiel im Offensivspiel, die Philosophie hatte zu sagen, da vorne macht ihr das schon, fühlt euch frei?
Ja, er hat sich natürlich dann auch gewisse Spieler als Verbündete gesucht, mit denen er gewisse Dinge bespricht.
Zum Beispiel?
Ja, Basti, Philipp, das waren ja dann auch die Kapitäne. Gerade die zwei waren immens wichtig für die weitere Entwicklung dann auch, weil sie Erfahrungen hatten, zusammen wissen, wie es funktioniert und hungrig waren, als Lieder voranzugehen. Und dann hat sich das eben so entwickelt, dass wir einfach hungrig waren.
Also es waren vielleicht auch sehr viele Eigenschaften, die gar nicht so sehr mit Taktik auf dem Platz zu tun hatten.
Nein, er wollte uns kompakt haben. Wir waren frisch, wir waren fit, wir waren homogene Truppe. Von der Qualität her haben wir uns noch mal gesteigert gegenüber dem letzten Jahr. Und er wollte eben, dass wir wenig zulassen, defensiv stabil sind, uns gut organisiert darstellen und dann auch attraktiven Fußball spielen. Aber mit Freiheiten, mit der Klasse, die wir selber einbringen können, mit der Eigenverantwortung, die wir selber haben. Und das hat er sensationell hinbekommen. Und wir haben eigentlich diese Saison mit 14, 15 Spielern gespielt, die danach kamen, waren nicht oft im Einsatz.
Trotzdem hat er es geschafft, alle Ballone zu behalten.
Und es waren trotzdem 50 Spiele. Sprich, wir waren sehr fit, wir waren überzeugt. Und er hat sie alle hinter sich gebracht und jeder hat sich gefügt, jeder hat seine Rolle angenommen und alles dafür getan, den Erfolg herbeizubringen und zu investieren, damit wir erfolgreich sind.
Jetzt war Jupp Heynckes nicht die einzige Veränderung, sondern es gab schon wieder neun Torhüter, diesmal Manuel Neuer. Wie ist es denn, wenn man jemanden mit solchen Fähigkeiten am Ball hinter sich hat? Hat sich das dann auch gleich in dein Spiel niedergeschlagen?
Ja, das hat man dann gespürt. Also Manuel war dann schon, wenn du einen im Rücken hast, der fußballerisch top ist, der antizipiert, der einfach ein Niveau hat, das unglaublich ist, dass du jeden Tag im Training siehst, miterleben darfst, wie er da hält, wie er dann in den Spielen hält. Er hatte keine leichte Anfangsperiode.
Meinst du damit, weil er umstritten war bei den Fans?
Ja, das war nicht einfach. Das ist nicht einfach, wenn man dann solche Gegenstimmen bekommt.
Wurde das thematisiert innerhalb der Mannschaft?
Innerhalb der Mannschaft nicht, aber klar hat man es mitbekommen. Es war keine einfache Zeit für ihn, aber für mich war immer klar, ich habe einen hinter mir, der unfassbar ist, der einfach Weltklasse ist und der mit Abstand für mich auch heute noch der beste Torhüter ist, wenn er fit ist.
Wir sind jetzt in der Zeit, 2010, 2012, in der Jürgen Klopp mit dem BVB so ein bisschen das Pressing und das Gegenpressing in deutschen Fußball gebracht hat. Was hat denn das für dich als Innenverteidiger bedeutet? Wurde man da in Spielen gegen Dortmund anders angelaufen, als man sonst die ganze Zeit in der Bundesliga erlebt hat?
Dortmund wusste man halt, dass sie im Kollektiv sehr stark sind und dass es eine sehr homogene Mannschaft ist, die schnell nach vorne spielt, aber auch wirklich gut gegen den Ball arbeitet, der Charaktere drin hat, die für stehen, den Ball zu obern, viel zu investieren, sich zu zerreißen, einfach dieses Konstrukt so zu beleben, dass ein schneller, aufwendiger und körperbetonter Fußball zustande kommt. Das war dann schon immer etwas Besonderes, gegen Dortmund zu spielen, weil man wusste, dass es schwer zu spielen wäre.
Du hast es damals auch schon so wahrgenommen, dass der BVB da ein neues Element in den Fußball gebracht hat. Und die Liga wurde ja insgesamt dann viel häufiger höher angelaufen, es wurde häufiger schnell ins Gegenpressen gegangen. Es war ja letztlich auch eine Veränderung, die dann der FC Bayern zur Saison 2013 auch mitgemacht hat. Hast du es damals auch schon so wahrgenommen, dass beim BVB einfach ein paar Dinge anders gemacht werden im Spiel grundsätzlicher Natur gegen den Ball und mit dem Ball?
Ja, ein bisschen schon wahrgenommen. Aber zu der Zeit war das für mich noch nicht so, dass ich mich im Detail damit befasst habe, sondern ich habe es wahrgenommen und es war natürlich zu sehen, dass damit auch natürlich auch Erfolg verbunden war. Aber ja, es war eben dann die Zeit, wo die Rivalität wieder wirklich auf dem Höhepunkt war und dem wollten wir an sich keine Blöde geben und Dortmund irgendwie pushen, sondern wir waren Bayern München und wir wollen die schlagen und egal wie.
Ist aber leider ja in der Saison, also leider aus deiner Sicht, nicht wirklich passiert. Zweimal gegen den BVB verloren und dann das Pokalfinale mit 2 zu 5 verloren. Kannst du denn dir im Nachhinein erklären, warum der BVB damals das Kryptonit für den FC Bayern war?
Es war eine homogene Truppe, es hat das eine Rad ins andere gepasst. Sie waren alle hungrig, es war eine Einheit, die auf dem Platz stand, wo wir es schwer hatten. Wir hatten die Prozente hinterher. Deswegen hat es dem Jahr letztendlich nicht gereicht, weil es sehr bitter war. Zum Glück hat man die richtigen Schlüsse rausgezogen. Aber sie waren da in gewissen Dingen einfach sehr, sehr gut. Jeder hat sich für den Ballgewinn, für die Mannschaft zerreißt. Man ist für den anderen da. Das war einfach bei Dortmund gegeben und bei uns oft gegeben, aber in den entscheidenden Phasen eben nicht. Das hat man dann auch rausgezogen. Auch wir Spieler, die den weiteren Weg bei Bayern gegangen sind, wir wussten natürlich dann schon auch noch mehr Bescheid, worauf es ankommt.
Es ist sehr gut, wie du immer, wenn ich über Niederlagen mit dir spreche, dann immer gleich den Bogenspanz zu den Dingen, wo es dann besser wurde. Da hast du den Spielaufbau auch gut drauf im miteinander sprechen. Dieses krasse Pokalfinale mit 2 zu 5 verloren und dann gab es ja noch das Finale daheim. Da warst du gesperrt, nach einer Karte in der Verlängerung im Halbfinale-Rückspiel gegen Real, ich glaube, in der 104. Minute oder so etwas.
Vor einem Jahr war es dann so, dass man die Karten gestrichen hat nach dem Viertelfinale, sodass eigentlich die beste Mannschaft auf dem Platz stehen konnte im Finale. Bei Chelsea hat, glaube ich, John Terry gefehlt. Da waren ja auch einige, die gesperrt waren. Bei uns waren es David, Gustavo, also David Alaba, Luis Gustavo und ich. Ich habe alle Spiele davor gespielt. Und dann durfte ich nicht auf dem Platz stehen, was so unverständlich für mich war, weil es einfach zu Hause, in München, im Wohnzimmer, Champions-League Finale, was willst du mehr? Und du darfst wegen so einer Regel nicht dabei sein. Das war einfach so bitter.
Aber du hast versucht, dich dann noch auf den Schiedsrichter einzuwirken. Als er dir die gelbe Karte gegeben hat?
Ja, gut, ich wusste natürlich sofort Bescheid. Wenn ich jetzt Geld kriege, dann... Und ich wusste, wie kommt das Finale. Ich wusste es zu der Zeit, obwohl es 2-1 für den Realaufstand war.
Ja, und dann im Elfmeterschießen und der entscheidende von Schweinsteiger. Und so ging es dann eben ins Finale Dahorn. Und man hatte damals den Eindruck, alles am FC Bayern war darauf ausgerichtet, in dieses Finale zu kommen. Uli Hoeneß hat schon ganz früh gesagt, auf der Jahreshauptversammlung, ich glaube im November, das Finale ist in unserer Stadt, da müssen wir dabei sein. Und so hat auch der ganze Verein agiert. Und im Nachhinein hatte ich das Gefühl, dass die Spieler, der Verein und auch das Umfeld völlig überdreht waren. Also es wurde die ganze Stadt, wo es sollte rot-weiß sein, es gab Aufrufe an die Fans, es war der perfekte Tag, es hätte das perfekte Finale werden können. Und wenn ich mir aber einfach nur angucke, wie das Spiel gelaufen ist, dann war das natürlich Pech, dass Chelsea im Grunde mit einer Chance das 1 zu 1 macht und dass man dann dieses Elfmeterschießen in dieser Art und Weise verliert. Aber gleichzeitig konnte man auch an ganz vielen kleinen Details sehen, dass auch die Spieler auf dem Feld keine Ruhe hatten. Also nicht nur jetzt irgendwelche verschossenen Strafstöße, sondern auch das nach dem 1 zu 0 von Moeller, Franck Ribéry, ich glaube in der 84. Minute oder so geht er schon zur Eckfahne in einem Konter, um quasi Zeit von der Uhr zu nehmen, wo er in der Bundesliga fünfmal von fünf Versuchen aufs Tor zugegangen wäre. War das so ein bisschen der Kern, warum dieses Finale dann auch verloren ging, dass man eben irgendwie einfach nicht die nötige Souveränität hatte? Kann man es darauf runterbrechen?
Ich glaube, da spielen ja viele Dinge mit ein. Für mich war das so aufregend und man hat gemerkt, da passiert heute Abend was. Da ist was und kommen. Es war so still. Ich bin mittags dann auch noch durch die Stadt gegangen. Das war so die Ruhe vor dem Sturm. Heute Abend soll dann die Nacht der Nächte kommen. Es war schon so eine gewisse Unruhe oder Aufgeregtheit zu spüren. Stress auch ein bisschen. Es muss gewonnen werden zu Hause. Das wäre der perfekte Abend. Und so hat man dann auch nach dem 1-0 gefeiert. Man ist vielleicht ein bisschen überdreht gewesen. Also nicht nur die Protagonisten, sondern eigentlich die ganze Stadt, also alle. Und das war einfach zu spüren, weil Chelsea in dem Spiel gar nichts gegenzusetzen. Und dann kommen sie eben so auch zum Tor und dann verschießen wir noch in der Verlängerung den Elfmeter und dann hast du schon gespürt, also irgendwas ist da heute, was nicht sein soll. Und dann das Elfmitterschied auch noch, das war dann einfach der bitterste Abend in der Vereinsgeschichte, ganz klar. Und für mich als Außenstehender…
Warst du dann wirklich außenstehend? Warst du dann auch bei Spielbesprechungen und so weiter?
Nein, ich habe Abschlusstraining mitgemacht, aber es ist einfach dann wichtig, dass auch die Mannschaft Ruhe hat und sich fokussieren kann. Ich habe mich dann dann rausgenommen und bin dann am nächsten Tag Richtung Stadion. Dann bin ich natürlich davor in der Kabine, etc.
Aber ist es nicht total hart, da nicht bei allen mit dabei zu sein?
Ja, schon. Aber das hat mich eben so geregelt. Ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr, ob es vorgegeben war, dass wirklich nur der Kader dann auch im Hotel sein sollte. Für mich war das okay. Da hätte mir das Herz geblutet, wenn ich alles mitmachen oder alles sehen durfte. Wenn es dann auf dem Platz geht, nicht rauszunehmen. Ich habe mich da eher ein bisschen abgelenkt. Aber ja, es stimmt schon. Es war so eine Stimmung in der Luft, wo du dann nach und nach merktest, irgendwie sollte es heute nicht sein.
Dabei ist ja auch noch das Elfmeterschießen perfekt losgelaufen. Aber gut, ich will jetzt nicht in den offenen Wunden bohren, wobei es sich leichter darüber reden lässt, weil wir jetzt in der Rückschau schon wissen, was dann noch kam.
Ja, man hat dann die Stärke daraus gezogen und natürlich die Gier daraus gezogen, endlich das verdammte Ding in den Himmel zu stricken.
Warst du dann nach Schlusspfiff bei der Mannschaft?
Da war ich unten, ja. Ja, das war totem Stille.
Wer ist der, der als Erstes was sagt in der Kabine nach so einem Spiel?
Da hat keiner was gesagt.
Da war vor sich hinredend, da war Stille, da war Fassungslosigkeit, Trauer, Tränen. Da war sehr, sehr viel, aber dass sich da dann einer hingestellt hat und irgendwie was Überflüssiges gesagt hat.
Ja, es würde ja auch reichen, dass jemand laut rumschreit.
Ja, nicht, dass ich mich jetzt erinnern könnte, dass jetzt einer irgendwie aufgefallen wäre.
Das war einfach schlimm. Habt ihr euch als Mannschaft dann noch mal gesehen, dann vor der nächsten Saisonvorbereitung, oder wann seid ihr da dann auseinandergegangen?
Ja, ich weiß ehrlich gar nicht, wie gesagt, so genau. Ich denke mal, dass wir danach schon zu einer Veranstaltung sind, was wir vorbereitet hatten im Fall der Fälle.
Aber du kannst dich nicht mehr genau drinnen erinnern? Alles wie im Schleier, was danach passiert ist. Aber an die EM 2012, können Sie dich noch erinnern?
Ja, da stand eben ein Turnier noch vor der Tür. Und da mit solchen Enttäuschungen reinzustarten, war nicht einfach. Aber für mich persönlich habe ich versucht abzuhaken. Und jetzt steht ein Turnier vor der Tür, wo wir auch Anwärter waren und uns die letzten Jahre weiterentwickelt hatten, sodass wir da schon eine sehr, sehr gute Rolle spielen würden. Das war dann schon so Bayern-Dopmond, auch so ein bisschen die Rivalität zusammen. Wie funktioniert das?
Im Nachhinein heißt es ja, das wäre ein bisschen ein Problem gewesen bei dem Turnier. Würdest du da zustimmen aus deiner Insicht?
Nicht so wirklich, nein. Es war ein bisschen zu spüren, aber es war dann eher von außen mehr draus gemacht.
Wie würdest du sagen, hat sich die Nationalmannschaft weiterentwickelt von der WM 2010? Wir haben ja vorhin viel drüber gesprochen, wie da Fußball gespielt wurde, jetzt zur EM 2012.
Ja, wir wurden auch anders gesehen. Deutschland kommt wieder, Deutschland hat einen Verein gehabt, der zwei Mal in drei Jahren im Champions-League-Finale war. Deutschland ist im Kommen. Auch die Nationalmannschaft hat in der letzten WM gut abgeschnitten. Also haben wir uns natürlich die Gegner auch anders gesehen. Die Medien haben uns natürlich auch anders dargestellt. Wir sind einer der Titelanwärter Spanien, Italien etc. Also wir wurden auch anders gesehen von der Presse, aber auch von unseren Gegnern. Der Fußball hat sich natürlich auch durch das, was wir Bayern-Spieler ein bisschen eingeimpft hatten. Dadurch, dass viele noch in der Nationalmannschaft waren, hat sich schon auch Richtung Ballbesitz entwickelt gehabt. Aber mit den Vorgaben des Bundes-Trainers, dass wir schon auch den Vorgaben, die uns in der WM stark gemacht hatten, weiter umsetzen und weiter verfeinern, dass wir durch unsere individuelle Qualität, durch unsere Schnelligkeit auch zu Torschancen kommen.
Also dann über das Umschaltspiel?
Ja, auch über das Umschaltspiel. Natürlich auch in gewisser Art und Weise zum Teil in gewissen Phasen Ballbesitzspiel. Aber es war ein bisschen anders aufgeteilt und andere Vorgaben mit der Idee des Bundes-Trainers. Das war schon zu unterscheiden. Aber dadurch, dass eben Bayern-Spieler da waren, haben wir das so ein bisschen mit eingeimpft.
Es war ja auch ein Bayern-Spieler da, der erst später einer werden sollte. Nämlich Mats Hummels, der hat an deiner Seite gespielt in der Innenverteidigung. Deutschland ist dann gegen Italien ausgeschieden bei dieser Europameisterschaft. Ist der Innenverteidigungspartner der wichtigste Spieler für dich als zweiter Innenverteidiger auf dem Platz?
Wie läuft da die Abstimmung? Du musst ihm vertrauen, dass er in gewissen Situationen einfach deinen Rücken frei hält, dich sichert. Das ist so, dass du einfach mit einer anderen Entschlossenheit und mit einer anderen Bewusstsein in den Zweikampf kannst. Weil du weißt, hinter mir ist noch einer, der ist eng da, der Raum ist eng, du kannst Risiko nehmen.
Und da ist es kein Thema, dass derjenige bei Borussia Dortmund zu dem Zeitpunkt noch spielt?
Ja, das muss sich natürlich auch entwickeln über die Spiele. Das fügt sich dann und nach und nach. Durch Siege ist es natürlich dann leichter, dich zu finden, wie wenn man es gegen Tore bekommt. Aber da hatten wir eigentlich einen guten Start mit Portugal, wo wir das 1-0 gewonnen haben. Dann hatten wir schon mal eine innere Gelassenheit und dann ging es auch weiter. Das war's für heute. Und trotzdem stand dann unser Fußball auch für dieses schnelle Umschalten und Abschluss suchen und den Gegner ein bisschen überrollen im Umschaltspiel. Da fächert es aus und dann kommt man zum Abschluss zu einer Torschau.
So war es dann gegen den Niederlanden im zweiten Konzert?
Genau, wo wir die dann rausgeschossen haben. Das war der Unterschied. Aber durch Siege und gewisse Aktionen im Spiel, wo man dann merkt, man kann ihm vertrauen, derjenige ist da, wenn man ihn braucht. Er spielt gute Bälle und wirkt sicher und hat die Ausstrahlung, dass ihm kein Fehler passiert.
Und wer gibt da die Kommandos in so einer Innenverteidigung Badstuber und Hummels?
Das waren wir beide gleich. Da unterstützt man sich gegenseitig und es war ja nicht nur wir beide, sondern es waren ja Philipp Niemir links und rechts wasser Scheroben, vor uns Basti und Sammy. Also da waren ja schon auch Charaktere auf dem Platz, die Verantwortung übernommen haben und die auch dirigiert haben.
Das Halbfinale gegen Italien. Der Angstgegner für Deutschland war damals auch natürlich sehr aufgeregte Stimmung in Deutschland, ob man das jetzt endlich mal schaffen würde. Vor wem hat man denn da als Abwehrspieler mehr Respekt? Vor Pirlo oder vor Balotelli? Mit dem einen hattest du ja wahrscheinlich mehr direkte Duelle und der andere hat aber die Pässe auf den einen geschlagen.
Ja, Respekt hat man immer vor jeder Nation, vor jedem einzelnen Spieler. Wir haben damals natürlich auch Italien analysiert. Und dann, wie sie ihren Weg bis zum Halbfinale gegangen sind, genauestens betrachtet und aufgezeigt bekommen. Dann hat aber der Bundesländer auch mit der Aufstellung her für Furore gesorgt und dort war es auch ein bisschen überrascht. Er hat uns auch überrascht, also mich hat er selber auch überrascht, weil wir bis zu dem Zeitpunkt eigentlich gut gefahren waren, mit gewissen Charakteren auf dem Platz und dann hat er ziemlich viel umgestellt.
Habt ihr das dann auch erst kurz vor sich erfahren? Also war nicht, dass ihr in dem Moment feststand, Italien wird der Gegner, dass Joachim Löw dann angekündigt hat, wir werden jetzt ein paar Dinge verändern, Toni Kroos soll Hürle ausgespielt haben.
Vielleicht mit dem 1 zu 1-Gespräch, aber ich wusste schon, dass ich spiele, also in der Innenverteidigung wird das wenig ändern, aber im Offensivbereich habe ich das jetzt so nicht erwartet gehabt.
Und konntest du die Aufregung darum nachvollziehen?
Ja, im Nachhinein klar, wenn es schief geht, ist dann immer Aufregung da. Ja, ich war damals einfach nur enttäuscht, weil ich hatte eigentlich das Gefühl, dass wir mehr erreichen hätten können und dass wir es eigentlich hergeschenkt haben.
Ja, als man dann das Finale gesehen hat, Spanien gegen Italien.
Da war es dann deutlich, weil Spanien war auf dem Höhepunkt natürlich auch, aber wir haben uns einfach gegen Italien nicht gut angestellt.
Spielt denn Italien einen anderen Fußball als Deutschland oder woher kommt das, dass sich deutsche Mannschaften so oft gegen italienische Mannschaften und vor allem in der Nationalmannschaft schwer tun?
Ich hatte eigentlich nur positiv… Ja, gut, klar.
Du bist da aber fast die Ausnahme.
Ja, konnte ich jetzt nicht so nachvollziehen. Klar war das dann immer so durch die Geschichte natürlich verständlich, aber ich hatte das nicht das Gefühl, dass wir jetzt ins Halbfinale gehen und irgendwie ein komisches Gefühl dabei hätten oder haben sollen, sondern es war ein Gegner, der sicherlich überrascht hat auch bei der EM, weil durch ihren Spielstil auch zu Toren zu kommen, aber zusätzlich unruhig oder so hat es mich nicht gemacht, was jetzt in der Geschichte passiert ist, sondern wie gesagt, ich war dann eher richtig enttäuscht, weil es war so ein unnötiges Spiel. Es war im Nachhinein einfach echt hergeschenkt, dass wir da nicht mehr rausziehen konnten, weil auf einmal 2-0 hinten sein und du weißt nicht so wirklich, warum und die machen einfach Tore, auch nach einem Eckball dann mal, wo der dann das Zweite macht. Das ist einfach, zu einfach und das ist eigentlich nicht unsere Art gewesen, so Tore zu zulassen.
War eigentlich das Thema dieses Jahr aus 2012, unnötig verlorene Spiele. Ist denn für dich Italien als Innenverteidiger ein besonderes Land? Also Italien war ja lange Zeit für seine defensive Spielweise bekannt und berüchtigt. Gibt es da besondere Vorbilder, an denen du dich orientiert hast?
Ja natürlich war Italien, gerade weil sie eben das Verteidigen gut konnten, es wurde nachgesagt, dass sie das Verteidigen eben exzellent beherrschen und dann auch Legenden entstanden sind, wie Maldini, Nesta, Cannavaro, zum Teil Weltfußballer. Für den Infteiliger war das dann schon schön.
Also guckt man da dann auch gerne?
Ja, natürlich. Aber es sind natürlich auch bedingt, weil sie tiefer standen, die Räume eng hatten, strikt waren. Es war jetzt nicht so dieses Ballbesitzspiel, sondern auch ein bisschen auf die individuelle Qualität dann nach vorne hin zu verlassen. Mit Totti, mit Del Piero, mit Cassano, eben die dann in der Phase, wo ich es dann ein bisschen erlebt habe. Oder wo sie dann auch Weltmeister wurden, so ein bisschen gespielt haben. Aber hinten waren sie immer einfach immer im Block, da war kein Durchkommen, das war wie eine Wand. Weil sie einfach sehr, sehr gut die Abstände hatten, die Räume gut verteidigen konnten, individuelle Qualität hatten und auch so eine Abgeklärtheit hatten, in wichtigen Phasen des Spiels eben auch nichts zuzulassen.
Das Gefühl, was du vorhin beschrieben hast, dass man die entscheidenden Zweikämpfe, die entscheidenden Aktionen, dass man da das Gefühl haben muss, okay, das geht jetzt nicht schief.
Das meine ich damit, ja. Aber die gesamte Mannschaft hatte das dann und ja, da war eben Klasse auf dem Platz, die eben wissen oder wussten, wie es funktioniert und da war eben, ja, das dann auch ausschlaggebend, dass sie dann auch erfolgreich hatten oder dass sie Erfolg hatten und da auch prädestiniert dafür waren, zu verteidigen und die Verteidigung eben auch ein großes Spiel herausgebracht hat.
Du hast ja viele interessante Länderspiele gemacht. Eins ragt so ein bisschen heraus, das ist dann im selben Jahr noch passiert. Du standest nämlich beim 4 zu 4 gegen Schweden auf dem Feld. Ich weiß nicht, ob du jetzt schon wusstest, ob jetzt dieses Spiel kommen wird. Kannst du mir erklären, wie so eine Dynamik entsteht?
Das war Wahnsinn, du spielst 35 Minuten mit dem besten Länderspiel in Berlin, das fühlt sich super an. Dann kriegst du aus dem Nichts ein Gegentor, dann gehst du in die Halbzeit, wir sind drei Tore vorne, jetzt reiß ich euch wieder zusammen. Aber zu diesem Kopfentscheid, dann gehe ich von hinten nach vorne. Dann mache ich die nötigen Schritte noch, muss ich so viel noch investieren, wir sind drei Tore vorne, es ist doch gegessen, das Spiel zu kommen. Das war eben nicht der Fall. Dann fiel es zwei, okay, Hoppala, dann vier, drei und dann kommt die Nervosität rein, dann kommt Unruhe rein, von außen Zuschauer, dann schlussendlich 4-4, das war abartig. Das Spiel, das einem nicht gerne in Erinnerung bleibt, an der anderen Seite hat man auch wieder so viel gelernt, was der Fußball dir dann verleeren zeigt und wie abartig der Fußball auch sein kann.
Dass du gerade als Abwehrspieler, hast du da dann noch öfter dran zurückgedacht bei kommenden Spielen, wo man mal so eine komfortable Führung hatte?
Nein, eigentlich nicht mehr, aber das Spiel war einfach die Ausnahme, sowas habe ich noch nie erlebt und das werde ich wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr erleben. Wenn du 4-0 vorne bist, kriegst du noch vier Gegentore. Ich habe allgemein nur nicht oft vier Gegentore bekommen in meinem Leben. Und dann auch noch, wenn du 4-0 vorne bist. Also das war, das war, ich wusste gar nicht mehr, was ich sagen sollte da.
Spielt es da noch eine Rolle, dass das gegen eine Mannschaft passiert, in der Zlatan Ibrahimovic spielt, ein Stürmer, der, wo man nie weiß, was größer ist, sein fußballisches Können oder das Ego?
Beides ist groß. Ja, nicht wirklich, weil wir haben es ja in den ersten 35 Minuten auch gesehen, wie es, wie es, wie er halt nicht zum Vorschein kam. Aber dann, er hat, glaube ich, ein Tor gemacht. Aber das war dann ein Versagen von der ganzen Mannschaft. Also klar, wir Abwehrspieler waren dann die Opfer des Ganzen und die Nichtsnutze, die normal nie mehr für Deutschland spielen durften. Aber das war ja das ganze Konstrukt, das er einfach versagt hat, weil in der ersten halben Stunde, 35 Minuten haben wir es nach vorne hin alle gut gemacht, nach hinten gut. Und dann hat sich das alles komplett 180 Grad gedreht und das war dann einfach echt heftig. Da bin ich ins Hotelzimmer danach gekommen, ich wusste gar nicht, wie es mir geschieht.
Das war so viel falscher Film irgendwie.
Und nicht zu fassen.
Jetzt das EM-Aus gegen Italien, dann dieses merkwürdige 4 zu 4 gegen Späden, jetzt sieben Jahre später. Kannst du es ja verraten. Was sagt einem Joachim Löw nach solchen Spielen?
Hat nach Spielen eigentlich nie was gesagt.
Auch nach dem EM-Aus?
Das war einfach eine Enttäuschung. Was soll er da groß sagen? Weiter geht es? Nein, es ist aus. Wir haben die Chancen nicht genutzt. Wir haben uns schlecht präsentiert. Also haben wir es nicht verdient, aber es war einfach unnötig. Das haben wir uns selber zuzuschreiben. Wir wissen, dass wir es viel besser machen können, weil die Qualität der Mannschaft sehr hoch ist. So was darf eigentlich nicht passieren.
Unnötig. Dann sind wir auch beim nächsten Thema. Im Spiel gegen Dortmund ist ja dann das Kreuzband gerissen. Wir alle wissen, da kamen dann auch noch ein paar Verletzungen. Neben all den Herausforderungen, die das für den Kopf bedeutet, wird mich interessieren, verändert das das Spiel, wenn man zurückkommt? Wie lange braucht man dann eigentlich wieder seine alte Passsicherheit zu haben?
Das war nicht die Frage. Ich war rausgerissen und nicht in der Lage zu spielen. Ich komme dann zurück und beobachte viel, was ich getan habe. Wir haben einen neuen Trainer, der sehr viel Fußballerisches Verständnis hat. Das ist unfassbar. Er setzt dir einfach noch mal auf den Topf zu dem, was ich bisher gelernt hatte. Er setzt dich drauf, geht dir in Detail, zeigt dir Lösungen auf, die plausibel sind, die er dir erklären kann, die du absolut abnickst und sagst, ja genau, genau so. Und letztendlich dann auch gezeigt bekommst und der Erfolg ihm auch recht gibt, dass man ihm vertrauen kann. Das alles habe ich dann natürlich versucht aufzusaugen, obwohl ich nicht auf dem Blatt stehen konnte. Und wenn du dann zurückkommst nach so einer langen Zeit, bei der du deinen Körper jetzt natürlich besser kennst, dein Körper ist anders wie davor. Es ist einfach so. Du bist erfahrener, du bist älter, du siehst die Dinge anders, du siehst das Geschäft anders, du siehst viele, viele Dinge anders. Nach so vielen Monaten, wo ich raus war. Aber du bist wieder am Start und du musst zuschauen, dass du Anschluss findest. Und ja, du bist natürlich auch gespannt und gewisserweise auch unruhig, wie du zurückkommst.
Aber ist denn dann so eine Passsicherheit, die ja für dich eben einfach immer wichtig war, neben Zweikampfführung und solchen Dingen und Kopfbeistärke, ist denn das gleich wieder da?
Ist das wie Fahrradfahren? Ja, nein, nicht gleich. Aber das kommt dann relativ schnell zurück. Das Gefühl kommt zurück. Das verlierst du jetzt nicht. Aber die Bewegungen, die Antizipation, jetzt Timing, die Schnelligkeit, das muss dann alles wieder sich finden. Der Körper muss sich finden. Doch die Abläufe, die müssen automatisiert werden. Die Wege, die du gehst im Spiel. Das ist alles, was du einfach durchs Training, aber speziell auch durch die Spiele wieder findest. Du findest dich dann wieder. Ich habe dann auch gesagt, ich bin nicht der Spieler, der ich mal war. Ich bin ein anderer Spieler. Heißt nicht, schlechter heißt nicht besser. Ich bin anders, weil ich einfach auch gewachsen bin in der Phase, persönlich gewachsen bin. Und durch das, was ich eben auch leider nur aufsaugen konnte, nicht auf dem Platz stand, habe ich natürlich trotzdem meinen Horizont erweitert, wie ich Fußball sehe. Der Fußball hat sich entwickelt, wie ich mich selber auf dem Platz verwirklichen will. Das bringe ich dann alles mit ein, wenn ich wieder zurückkomme. Das habe ich versucht. Ich bin gut zurückgekommen. Nach 18 Monaten. Hättest du auch gleich wieder gespielt. Ja, genau. Dann natürlich gleich gespielt. Was dann vielleicht auch nicht gut war für meinen Körper, weil nach 18 Monaten muss ich den Körper einfach langsam wieder dran gewöhnen. Ich war sofort wieder am Start.
Aber das war ja auch so ein bisschen Philosophie von Guardiola, der damals gesagt hat, wenn die medizinische Abteilung gesagt hat, ein Spieler kann trainieren, dann kann er ja auch spielen.
Ja, aber nach 18 Monaten hat der Körper die Zeit gebraucht. Er war 18 Monate raus aus diesen Bewegungen, aus diesem Rhythmus, aus dieser Belastung, aus dieser Härte, aus der Regeneration. Das geht nicht so einfach. Wenn du mal zwei Wochen raus bist, drei Wochen, brauchst du selbst da, brauchst du mal so zwei, drei Tage. Aber in 18 Monaten kannst du nicht in ein, zwei, drei Monaten diese Selbstverständlichkeit mehr haben, auch von deinem Körper abzuverlangen. Der funktioniert wieder vor. Und du hast noch Einschnitte im Körper. Der Körper ist nicht mehr so wie davor. Der ist mich jungfreudig, sag ich mal.
Erinnert das dann zum Beispiel auch die Zweikampfführung?
Ja, das war dann auch so ein Schlüsselerlebnis, wo ich dann hatte im Training, da habe ich dann eine voll ins Knie gekommen und dann wusste ich, dass das Ding hält. Und dann war auch im Kopf die Blockade oder diese Hürde weg. Dass da kann dann nochmal was passieren, ist meine Schwachstelle. Heutzutage ist gar nicht mehr meine Schwachstelle.
Bevor wir mal kurz über Pep Guardiola sprechen oder gerne auch länger, würde ich mit dir gerne noch dann über den Mai 2013 sprechen. Da hast du dir erneut das Kreuzband gerissen, eine Woche vor dem Champions-League-Finale zwischen Bayern und Dortmund und das Spiel dann in den USA verfolgt und gar nicht in London. Kannst du mir mal kurz beschreiben, was war das wieder für eine verrückte Woche für dich? Und gab es keine Option, in London dabei zu sein, oder wolltest du es gar nicht?
Es war ein bisschen anders. Mein Knie hat sich die ganze Zeit nicht gut angefühlt gehabt. Und es war dann schlussendlich einfach der Fakt, dass ich da nochmal eine Operation stattfand. Oder da muss eine neue Operation, das Kreuzband muss erneuert werden.
Also es hat sich nicht richtig gut angefühlt, nachdem wir das OP verhalten?
Ja, ich hatte vier OPs. Es hat sich einfach nach der ersten OP nicht gut angefühlt. Und dann hat sich das einfach auch so weitergezogen und schlussendlich…
Aber da wirst du doch wahnsinnig.
Ja, natürlich. Das ist das Schlimmste. Ich wusste nicht so wirklich, ich tue alles dafür, aber ich hatte noch nie eine Verletzung. Ist das normal? Muss ich das erst adaptieren? Diese innere Unruhe und dann halt auch diese Ungeduld mit 23 oder 22, 23. Habe ich das nicht gehabt, dass ich einfach sage, okay, jetzt bin ich raus, ich komme zurück. Ich tue alles dafür, aber kein Stress. Das Ding muss einfach sitzen. So, auf jeden Fall ist dann dazu gekommen, dass ich wirklich… dass wir alle mit den Ärzten zusammen den Schluss hingefasst haben, dass ich ein neues Kreuzband brauche. Ich wollte nicht mehr bei den alten Ärzten sein. Ich brauchte was Neues und ich bin nach Amerika. Genau, eine Ikone damals oder ist eine Ikone für mich. Ja, für mich ein ganz wichtiger…
Du hast gerade zum Himmel geblickt.
Ja, er war derjenige, der mich dafür gesorgt hat, dass das Bombenfest ist und dass ich nie mehr Probleme damit hatte nach vier OPs. Da bist du dann schon sehr dankbar.
Musstest du das dann vor dem Champions-League-Finale sein oder wolltest du gar nicht dabei sein?
Da geht es dann auch um mich und um meine Gesundheit. Ich war eh schon fünf Monate raus. Das musste jetzt passieren, das musste jetzt gemacht werden und dann habe ich auch ein besseres Gefühl. Weil nochmal warten, nochmal warten… Nein, die OP muss jetzt vonstatten gehen. Da muss ich leider das Ding vom Fernseher aus sehen. Aber das war es für mich zu der Zeit, weil es einfach so geschmerzt hat, dass ich bis zum Winter alles gespielt habe. Und dann, ich wusste, dem Jahr sind wir dran, da ist einfach die Dynamik da, das Team ist so gut, die Qualität ist da, die Erfahrung ist da, die Gier ist da, es passt alles, es ist Ruhe im Verein. Wir haben alle das gleiche Ziel, diese Energie war da. Und ich wusste, das wird eine große Saison. Und das hat dann einfach für mich so geschmerzt, dass ich einfach leider nicht mehr teil sein konnte in der zweiten oder einer Rückserie, obwohl ich davor alles gespielt habe. Da war ich froh, dass ich in Amerika war. Amerika ist ein Land, wo Fußball jetzt nicht so hochgepriesen wird, Randsportart sozusagen. Die Übertragung war auch Ampfiff, Abpfiff, da von den Feierlichkeiten nichts mehr zu sehen war. Was aber für mich gut war, weil…
Wie viel Uhr Ortszeit war das dann?
Was war das Mittags? Ich glaube, Denver oder Vail Colorado, ich glaube, ein bisschen zurück.
Ja, dann kommt es ungefähr hin mit Mittag, genau. Und dann hast du quasi die Pokalübergabe gar nicht mehr gesehen?
Nein, das habe ich im Internet gesehen, aber zu der Zeit war das einfach… ja, es hat so geschmerzt, dass ich nicht… wenn ich fit bin, hätte ich gespielt. Gut, ich habe einen Teil dazu beigetragen, aber ich würde halt gerne dabei sein, wenn es wichtig ist, wenn es wichtig wird. Leider konnte ich das nicht, aber andererseits ging es jetzt um meine Gesundheit, um meine weite Karriere. Wenn da jetzt nochmal was schief geht, dann mal schauen, was dann passiert. Nach vier Operationen, oder nach damals drei, war es dann einfach gut und ich habe dann gesagt, okay, jetzt geht es vor, es geht um meine Karriere, ich bin so jung und das muss jetzt passen. Ich nehme alles auf mich, ich gehe nach Amerika zu der Ikone, wo einfach ich auch ein gutes Gefühl habe. Ich bin weg, geht den ganzen Trubel nicht mit. Ich habe meine Ruhe und habe neue Leute um mich herum. Das war ganz wichtig für mich, dass ich da nicht mehr in diesem alten Umfeld war.
Wie hast du dann mitbekommen, dass dich deine Mitspieler gegrüßt haben aus London heraus?
Durch das Internet, bzw. durch SMS oder WhatsApp. Da wurden mir dann Bilder geschickt, die mich natürlich gerührt haben. Aber der Schmerz war einfach da, von der OP oder vom Körperlichen. Aber auch der seelische Schmerz war einfach so groß, dass sie mich gerührt hat. Aber es tut gleichzeitig weh. Aber es tut einfach zu weh.
Dann wollen wir über angenehmere Dinge sprechen. Pep Guardiola, du bist vorhin schon so, hat dich das Gefühl so ein bisschen ins Schwärmen geraten. Sag mir, was ist Pep Guardiola für einen Trainer für dich gewesen? Ich meine, du hast so tolle Trainer erlebt. Louis van Gaal, Jupp Heynckes, Pep Guardiola. Da würden sich viele wirklich die Finger nach lecken, unter denen trainieren zu dürfen. Sag mir mal, was kam mit Guardiola noch zum FC Bayern, was neu war?
Ja, diese Zeit von Barcelona, die hat ihn natürlich geprägt. Und der Trainer, der Welttrainer, der den Fußball weitergebracht hat, der zu der Zeit einfach auf einer anderen Stufe stand, der über allem stand, der Barcelona einen Stempel aufgedrückt hat, den sie nicht so schnell loswerden und der einfach den Fußball dominiert und beherrscht hat – mit Hilfe seiner Spieler, seiner Großartigen. Unter ihm zu trainieren, da war es aufregend, wo ich gehört habe, dass Pep Trainer wird. Selbst da, wo ich auf dem Hof Krücken war, habe ich mich gefreut. Boah, krass, er hat mich auch versucht anzurufen, das weiß ich noch. Ich glaube einfach, um mir auch ein Gefühl zu geben. Er kennt mich und er will mit mir arbeiten, das weiß ich noch. Da war ich in Vail in den USA und das war für mich einfach schon mal zu Beginn so einfach was Schönes, Wertschätzung, auch menschliche Klasse, wo ich sagen, wo ich einfach schon mal ein guter Start war. Ich habe zwar das erste Saison aber ja nicht gespielt. Da war ich ja völlig raus. Aber ich habe aufgesorgt, was nur geht und mich mit ihm unterhalten. Er hat mir alle Freiheiten gelassen. Er wollte nur einfach, dass es mir gut geht, dass ich zurückkomme. Er hatte immer ein Ohr offen. Ich konnte immer zu ihm gehen. Ich konnte auf ihn zugehen. Das war einfach Sympathie. Im zweiten Jahr habe ich dann sofort auch gespielt. Klar, da war dann die Weltmeister auch ein bisschen später dran. Aber ich habe gespielt. Er hat mir sofort das Vertrauen gegeben. Klar, wenn du fit bist, bist du fit. Das spielst du. Das war dann auch später ein Thema im Verein. Und dann diese großen Diskussionen und die große Unruhe mit Möller-Wohlfahrt etc. medizinische Abteilung, das ist ein Thema für sich. Aber ja, das war schon auch für meinen Fußballverstand viel. Was er dir auf dem Weg mitgegeben hat, wie er die Spiele angeht, wie er den Gegner analysiert, wie du das Spiel dominieren wirst, wenn du das und das und das machst. Das war krass. Also zu Beginn war das krass. Vor allem, wenn du dann wirklich mal dabei bist und die Besprechung mitmachst, das Training mitmachst, dass du darauf abgestimmt bist, seine Vision in den Kopf eingeprägt hast. Das ist schon ein hohes Niveau.
Hat er euch dann gleich von Anfang an gesagt, was er von euch erwartet? Ich weiß noch, dass die große Diskussion damals war, würde Bayern noch flanken, weil ja bei Barca Ecken kurz ausgeführt wurden und es wurden keine Flanken mehr geschlagen. Aber man hatte ja die entsprechenden Stürmer vorne drin, um Flanken zu schlagen. Hat er sich in den ersten Trainingseinheiten oder nach ein paar Wochen hingestellt und hat gesagt, meine Vision für unser Spiel ist Folgendes, oder kam das alles so stückweise mit dieser Überforderung?
Stückweise. Aber wir hatten ja intelligente Spieler, die das schnell begriffen haben, überzeugt waren. Er hat viel gesprochen und viele Details. Er war schon zu Beginn eine Überzeugung da. Und das hat sich ja sofort auch anders angefühlt auf dem Platz. Und dann hat sich das Stück für Stück… Natürlich geht das nicht von heute auf morgen, aber er hat es schon mit einer Überzeugung gemacht, mit einem Trainingsinhalten gemacht, wo dich das dann da hinführt, dass es irgendwann automatisch so läuft. Und mit dem Hintergrund, was er da in Barcelona geleistet hat, da glaubst du dran.
Und diese Überforderung war das nicht… Das ist ja durchaus erstaunlich, dass man so hochtalentierte Spieler noch überfordern kann. Ist das häufiger so? Oder ist das jetzt etwas Spezielles, Pep Guardiola? Mit so vielen Details überladen, meine ich.
Ja, überladen, ja. Das war dann einfach für jeden Spieler auch eine Herausforderung, damit klarzukommen, Leistung zu bringen, aber trotzdem das zu verinnerlichen. Aber da war die Mannschaft eigentlich zu gut und da irgendwie das nicht umsetzen zu können. Das haben wir eigentlich relativ gut hinbekommen.
Und wie hat sich dann die Rolle des Innenverteidigers unter Pep Guardiola verändert?
Ja, gerade im Spielaufbau, wie du dich anbietest, wenn gerade der Gegner spielt, was dann für Räume für dich sichergeben, in welche Räume du reinkommst, in welche Räume du passen kannst, Verlagerung. Das hat dir schon in Perfektion aufgezeigt. Das war ein einfacher Spiel für mich.
War das dann noch mal detaillierter als zum Beispiel bei Louis van Gaal, wo du ja vorhin auch schon gesagt hast, dass er genau gesagt hat, in welchem Raum du, wann welches Spiel.
Es war noch mal eine Stufe drüber, noch detaillierter.
Mehr auf den Gegner angepasst oder genauer in den Anweisungen, wie und was du tun sollst?
Beides. Pep hat dir genau auf dem Silbertablett da gezeigt oder aufgezeigt, wie du es machst und dann wirst du gewinnen. Und das war von vornherein klar, wenn wir so machen. Wir haben die Qualität, wir haben den Kopf dazu, das umzusetzen. Wir haben die Intelligenz, das auf dem Spielfeld zu erkennen. Auch wenn der Gegner mal umstellt.
Diese Umstellung innerhalb des Spiels, das hat ja auch Pep Guardiola so ein bisschen auf die Spitze getrieben beim FC Bayern. Wie läuft da die Kommunikation während des laufenden Spiels? Aber es gab da mehrere Beispiele. Es gab da zum Beispiel ein Spiel gegen Ingolstadt. Da hat er dann auch dich auf die Linksverteidigerposition gezogen und dann wurde das Spiel gedreht. Aber im Grunde ist es ja bei Pep Guardiola oft schon so gewesen, dass nach zehn Minuten die erste Umstellung kam. Er hat sich angeguckt, was macht der Gegner, und dann kommt die Umstellung. Da haben manche Journalisten auch argumentiert, das könnt ihr auch dafür sprechen, dass einfach der erste Plan schlecht war. Wie siehst du es denn als Spieler, der es ausgeführt hat?
Ja, aber wenn der Gegner dann vielleicht noch kleine Details auch verändert hatte, er hat gesagt, er weiß nach zwei, drei Minuten, welche Räume wir bespielen müssen, um voranzukommen, um Linien zu überspielen, um die nächste Ebene zu erreichen, um dann letztendlich auch unsere Qualität im Offensiven zum Tragen zu bringen, um Tore zu machen. Das hat er nach zwei, drei Minuten erkannt, eigentlich dann auch von uns gefordert. Ihr müsst eigentlich nach fünf Minuten wissen, wie ihr spielt oder wie ihr den Gegner bespielen müsst.
Und kann man das auf dem Feld? Man hat ja noch durchaus was anderes zu tun.
Klar, ich denke schon, dass wir das können, weil wir haben so viele intelligente Spieler gehabt, die auch untereinander kommuniziert haben. Pass auf, das ist der freie Mann. Wenn der die Bewegung macht, du bist der freie Mann. Du wirst immer wieder frei, wenn wir die und die Stafetten machen, wenn wir die und die Fräume freien ziehen, bist du der Mann, der dann Entscheidendes für die nächste Ebene oder für den entscheidenden Raum gewinnt.
Pep Guardiola hat über dich gesagt, es gäbe wenige, wenige Verteidiger auf der Welt mit dieser Qualität am Ball. Und außerdem gibt es natürlich das berühmte Zitat, er ist der Beste, den ich je hatte.
Gut, da ist er ein bisschen euphorisch gewesen, aber es war schön. Er war einfach immer dabei, immer mit ganzen Emotionen dabei, mit Leib und Seele dabei in jeder Trainingseinheit. Und wie gesagt, auch in seiner Vorbereitung, da gibt es nichts anderes, außer Fußball, das ist krass. Das war auch zu erleben. Er war ja gegen die Videos geschaut, analysiert, trainiert, es einfach so detailverliebt. Das war schon krass zu sehen. Natürlich mit seinen Aussagen, das freut einen, aber man muss den Ball auch ein bisschen flach halten, weil aus Euphorie passiert, dann sagt man dann mal Dinge. Aber ich habe ihm vertraut und ich weiß, dass er viel von mir hält, auch als Mensch. Das ist mir auch wichtig, speziell als Mensch, dass ich mit ihm ein sehr gutes Verhältnis gepflegt habe. Wenn ich ihn mal wieder sehe, freue ich mich total. Das bleibt auch und darf nie in Vergessenheit geraten, dass es eigentlich auch ums Menschliche geht.
Jetzt hat Pep Guardiola ein paar fußballerische Prinzipien. Ein paar davon erschließen sich automatisch in die berühmte Zone 14 vor dem Strafraum. Da möchte man reinkommen, weil da kann man gefährliche Pässe spielen, Verlagerungen, ähnlich wie unter Van Raal, aber ein bisschen anders ausgeführt haben, eine Rolle gespielt, aber bloß nicht ins tödliche U rein kommen, also nur um die Strafräume außenrum. Das hat ihm dann nicht zu gefallen. Aber dann gab es auch dieses eine Guardiolasche Prinzip, was sich mir nicht gleich erschlossen hat. Nämlich hat er von euch gefordert, so ist es zumindest zu lesen gewesen in dem Buch über ihn in der Zeit, dass man eine gewisse Anzahl von Pässen in der eigenen Hälfte spielen soll, bevor man dann den Ball ins Angriffstrittel nach vorne spielt.
Nee, nicht unbedingt.
Also ihr musstet nicht die Pässe mitzählen. Aber ging es dann darum, das habe ich dann später auch nochmal gelesen in Aussagen, dass die Art und Weise, in welchem Tempo man den Ball nach vorne spielt, eine Bedeutung hat für das Spiel gegen den Ball, sollte man den Ball verlieren. War das eins deiner Prinzipien? War das wichtig für dich?
Nicht unbedingt, aber klar sind es Details, die aber auch die Qualität des Spielers ausmachen. Welche Geschwindigkeit er den Ball spielen kann, welche Genauigkeit, welchen Timing er oder wann er den Ball spielt, das war ihm schon wichtig. Wann die Bewegung des Mitspielers kommt, das muss zum richtigen Zeitpunkt kommen, welche Räume sich dann öffnen, wo der Mitspieler wieder rein muss. Das waren die Dinge, wo er uns vorgelegt hat. Er hat uns nicht gesagt, den Pass dürfte er nicht spielen, oder den Pass muss er in die Geschwindigkeit spielen. Da hatten wir genug Qualität, um selber zu wissen, wie wir Bälle spielen. Er hat uns aufgezeigt, wie gewisse Mechanismen laufen, um weiter voranzukommen. Gerade von hinten, wenn sie zwei Stürmer haben, hat er meistens mit einer Dreierkette aufgebaut. Dann spielen wir drei gegen zwei hinten, dann sind wir schon mal eins weiter. So geht es dann im Mittelfeld. Der lässt sich nach außen fallen, der kommt rein. Dann kam Philipp von rechts außen rein. Das waren ja oft Mechanismen, wo wir dann einfach den freien Mann gefunden hatten. Manchmal war es der Nr. 8, manchmal war es der 6, manchmal war es der 10. Irgendwann war einer frei und den mussten wir finden.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass es bei Pep Guardiola um zwei Dinge im Kern geht, jenseits von allen Details. Das eine ist ein sauberes, effizientes und möglichst mit wenigen Kontakten aufgezogenes Passspiel. Dafür hat er auch die Rondos im Training etabliert. Das zweite ist, es geht oft um Überzahl in wichtigen Räumen. Ihm ist ganz wichtig, vor allem im Mittelfeld Überzahl herzustellen. Und wenn man im Angriffstrittel ist, dann auch eins gegen eins Situationen zu kreieren, für diejenigen, die diese spielerisch auflösen können. Oder eben dann in gefährlichen Zonen eine Überzahl hinzubekommen. Das hört sich ehrlich gesagt vor allem diese Passspielkomponente gar nicht so hochwissenschaftlich an, sondern eher trivial an. Und trotzdem hatte ich den Eindruck, dass der FC Bayern in der Zeit unter Guardiola eine höhere Genauigkeit und eine höhere Passschärfe und auch ein höheres Bewusstsein für den Ball und für den Raum hatte, als in vielen anderen Jahren.
Ja, das hat er schon geschaffen. Aber wir hatten auch Xabi Alonso, der unfassbares Passspiel hat. Sowohl Kurzpass oder diese scharfen Pässe dann auch verlagern. Links, rechts ein super Raumgefühl hatte. Basti war zu der Zeit – Basti ist auch Passspiel. Also wir hatten auch die Spieler, die einfach ein gutes Passspiel hatten, um dann wirklich die wichtigen Szenen auch einzuleiten mit entscheidenden Bällen. Aber es ist definitiv so, wie du sagst. Also so sehe ich das auch. Dass es zu der Zeit extrem aufgefallen ist, dass jeder passen Sinn machte, jeder pass exakt war, dominiert, mit Überzeugung gespielt war, mit Sinn und Verstand – fast schon krass, fast schon übertrieben.
War dann das Übertriebene vielleicht auch das, was dann gegen Ende der Ära Guardiola bei Bayern so ein bisschen in den Vordergrund kam? Also man war sehr erfolgreich, man hat die Liga nach Belieben dominiert. In der Champions-League ist man aus verschiedenen Gründen dreimal in Folge im Halbfinale ausgeschieden. Einmal ein bisschen zu offensiv im Rückspiel angegangen, einmal Verletzungspech. Ich simplifiziere jetzt, aber so grob kann man es stehen lassen. Und gegen Atletico, das war einfach Pech. Da hat ja auch Diego Semignone danach gesagt, das war die beste Leistung gegen Atletico, die er vorher schon mal gesehen hätte. Und man hatte aber das Gefühl, gerade in den Spielen, die jetzt nicht auf Champions-League-Ebene stattfanden, dass es sich manchmal auch ein bisschen im Passspiel verloren hat. Also dass es dann fast um das Passspiel willen war.
Ja, es war mal ein bisschen so der Schein, dass es eigentlich um die Dominanz ging und dass wir die Gegner so dominieren mit dem Passspiel und dann mit Chancen uns kreieren. Aber es geht um Tore, es geht um Gewinnen. Wir dürfen bestimmte Dinge nicht vernachlässigen. Es geht nicht nur ums Passspiel.
Und war das jetzt dann nur der Schein oder war das vielleicht auch manchmal in Spielen so?
Vielleicht haben wir uns auch als Mannschaft ein bisschen darin verloren, nur auf das zu achten und dann halt Gegner wie zum Beispiel Madrid zuhause. Die haben sich dann halt auch voreingelassen, aber die wussten ganz genau.
Eine Chance kriegen wir.
Ja, wir kriegen eine Chance. Die waren ja auch eine Weltgruppe, die wissen schon auch, wie es funktioniert und wie es ankommt. Aber wir warten und wir lauern. Und die haben auch schön auf Kontakt gespielt.
Ja, die eine Aktion. Jérôme Boateng spielt einen Unsorgenpass, geht ins Gegenpressing, in seinem Rücken ist Grießmann schon weg und dann kriegt er den Ball. So schnell geht es dann eben einfach. Unter den großen Trainern, unter denen du spielen durftest, ist auch mit Carlo Ancelotti jemand, den man schon als Experte fürs Verteidigen bezeichnen könnte. Er hat im zentralen, manchmal defensiven Mittelfeld selber gespielt und unter Ariko Saki mit Milan zweimal den Cup der Landesmeister, die Champions League, in einem Team mit Barresi, Maldini, Raikart, Van Basten gewonnen. Hattest du das Gefühl, dass jemand wie Ancelotti, der ja auch der italienischen Schule verhaftet ist, anders über das Verteidigen denkt als deine anderen Trainer, die du hattest?
Über Ancelotti kann ich gar nicht so viel sagen. Das waren ja die Jahre davor von Pep, da war so viel Input. Bei Ancelotti war das gar nicht mehr so der Fall. Da haben die Spieler anders als am Anfang gedacht, wir sind wieder frei, gerade so kreativer.
So hieß es auch am Anfang, dass Ancelotti die Fesseln gelöst hätte.
Genau, er lässt die Spieler wieder frei sein auf dem Spielfeld. Aber einen Plan habe ich nicht wirklich gesehen. Es war für mich so, dass er uns die Verantwortung gegeben hat. Ihr wisst doch, wie es funktioniert. Ich schnür euch nicht ein, ihr seid frei. Ich gebe euch ein paar Details mit, aber mehr nicht. Wir waren davor Pep gewohnt. Das war bis ins kleinste Detail. Das hat uns schon sehr viel abgenommen. Das war am Anfang Angelo's Zeit befreiend für viele Spieler. Aber was ist der Fußball bei uns da gestanden? Wir hatten einen Kopf, Pep, Passen, Dominanz. Aber was wollte er von Fußball spielen? Weiß ich nicht.
Wie unterscheidet sich das jetzt? Wenn man das in der Rückschau betrachtet, hat man das Gefühl, da gab es zwei sehr strukturierte, ordnungsliebende und auch viele regeln vorgebende Trainer, nämlich van Gaal und Guardiola. Und es gab zwei, die eher Freiheiten gelassen haben, Prinzipien vielleicht mitgegeben haben. Und wo man dann eben einfach bei einem, bei Jupp Heynckes, dieses Gefühl hatte, für diesen Trainer, da würden wir alle doof gesagt durchs Feuer gehen. Und man hat sich hinter dem gemeinsamen Ziel vereint. Und bei Carlo Ancelotti, der hatte ja den Ruf, genau das auch zu schaffen. Und schafft es ja jetzt vielleicht gerade auch bei Napoli wieder. Kann man das so einfach runterbrechen, dass es zwei Regeln, Trainer waren und zwei...
Ja, okay, klar, die anderen waren dadurch mehr geprägt. Aber bei Jupp war dann... Gut, ich sehe das natürlich auch anders, weil ich einfach bei Jupp auch immer gespielt habe, bei Ancelotti wenig Chancen bekam.
Weißt du warum?
Ja, gut, da hatte ich einfach auch nicht mit dem Standing. Ich war viel verletzt davor und dann wurde Mats Hummels geholt. Ja, da spielt halt der. Also das ist einfach so. Da geht es dann um Standing. Ich meine, das sind zwei Weltmeister mit Jerome und ihm, die haben einfach gespielt. Da war ja noch Javi Martínez vor mir in der Innenverteidigung. Dann habe ich das auch gar nicht mehr so nah am mich reingelassen. Andererseits muss man aber auch sagen, wir waren mit Jupp einfach total fit. Jupp Heynckes hat es einfach geschafft, Fitness mit Menschlichkeit zu kombinieren, mit präzisen guten Ansagen. Natürlich nicht so detailliert und viel wie Pep, aber er hat genau die richtigen Worte getroffen. Den Spiel dann auch die Verantwortung gegeben, die sie tragen können und den Spiel dann freien Raum gelassen, die eben kreativ sein mussten und auch freien Raum gelesen wollten. Das war einfach eine perfekte Mischung. Bei Angelotti war das dann, ich weiß nicht, das war manchmal ein komisches Gefühl, weil ich nicht wusste, was will er eigentlich, was sollen wir spielen, was will er, was gibt er uns für Vorgaben. Sind wir fit? Weiß ich nicht. Er hat nie klar gesagt, ich will das und das von dir sehen, als Innenverteidiger, von dir als Spieler. Ich habe einfach keine Chance bekommen. Das war bei mir so der Fall. Das waren vier, fünf Monate, da war ich ja eh dann auch weg. Von daher kann ich jetzt über Carlo Angeli – das hat halt nicht sollen sein zwischen uns. Und mei, zwischen Bayern und ihm anscheinend auch nicht. Weil es hat ja auch nicht jetzt lang gehalten und die Zeit bleibt jetzt auch nicht so in Erinnerung in der Vereinshistorie, finde ich.
Du bist dann zu Schalke 04 gewechselt und damit ja auch von einem Ballbesitzteam zu einer Mannschaft, die zwar in manchen Spielen auch viel Ballbesitz hatte, aber bei Schalke gab es ja auch durchaus mal Spiele, wo sich das verändert hat. Und gleichzeitig haben da viele Innenverteidiger gespielt, Höwedes, Dambouli, Naldo, Aihaan und Thilo Kehrer. Und du kamst so noch mit dazu unter Markus Weinziel als Trainer. Wie hat sich denn jetzt aus taktischer Sicht das Spiel auf Schalke von dem, vom Bayern, unterschieden, was du ja im Grunde dein ganzes fußballerisches Leben bis dahin gespielt hast?
In allem, weil ich gar nicht wusste, was... also erstens war das ja eine Zeit für mich, wo einfach, ja, Abschied von Bayern war nach 14, 5 Jahren einfach nicht so, wie ich es mir gewünscht hätte. Ja, das war so schnell und irgendwie ungutes Gefühl dabei, unguter Abschied, traurig.
Aber du hattest den Abschied initiiert, oder?
Naja, also wenn man halt keine Chance kriegt und so ein bisschen beiläufig so ein bisschen mitkriegt und so, dass es vielleicht mal ganz gut wäre, wenn ich halt einfach Spielpraxis sammle. Ja, warum soll ich dann da bleiben? Ich will kicken, ja. Gerade nach meiner Zeit, da ich einfach verhindert war, zu spielen, das war ja nie wegen Leistung. Ich war einfach aus körperlicher Sicht her nicht im Stande zu spielen. Und das hat mir schon wehgetan, auf die Art und Weise von München wegzugehen. War dann auch für mich ganz klar, ich bin jetzt vier oder viereinhalb Monate bei Schalke und dann ist ein Schlusspunkt und dann orientiere ich mich neu.
Also war das auch klar, dass du danach nicht zurückkommst?
Ja, das war einfach nur politisch irgendwas geredet von Protagonisten aus Schalke. Für mich war von vornherein klar, meine Wohnung war auf fünf Monate gemietet. Es war alles auf fünf Monate gerecht, ich wollte einfach nur spielen. Die Interesse kam von Schalke, man wollte mich haben, weil es auch nicht so gut lief, obwohl die Mannschaft gut war. Also im Schluss kam der elfte Platz raus, ich weiß nicht, wie es mit der Mannschaft geht, dass man da elfter wird.
Aber es war auch klar, dass du nicht zu Bayern zurückkommst, weil es war so eine Geschichte, dass laut DFL-Statuten…
Nein, für mich war einfach klar, wie es dann auch mit Verträgen und so weiter, mit gewissen… das war dann nicht mein Bier, sondern das wurde dann geregelt von Pirate etc. Aber für mich war dann klar, ich gehe immer von Bayern weg, aber ich habe bei einem Trainer nicht die Chance bekommen, der mir nie einen Feedback gegeben hat, der mir nie… da war einfach keine Verbindung da. Ich will jetzt auch nicht nachtreten, weil das hat einfach nicht gefruchtet, Punkt. Und dann war für mich klar, am Sommer… schauen wir mal, was dann passiert. Das erste Mal ist für mich wichtig, gesund zu bleiben. Das halbe Jahr, das habe ich geschafft. Und nüchtern betrachtet war das dann für mich einfach das A und O, gesund zu bleiben. Die Zeit war… Anfangs war es okay, aber hat sich dann… Also das hätte ich dann im Schluss nicht gebraucht auf Schalke. Also Verein hat Potenzial, tolle Fans, Stadion super. Aber das sind einfach Dinge auch passiert, wo ich sage, kann dich nicht… Wie gesagt, auch mit dem Schluss, was am Schluss passiert ist, das waren einfach Lügen. Dass sie irgendwie nicht mit mir verlängern wollten. Für mich war nie… Das stellt alles auf Frage, dass ich jetzt auf Schalke bleiben will. Oder dass ich da jetzt noch einen Vertrag will. 0, 0. Es war immer so, vier Monate, ich will Spielpraxis und dann will ich gesund sein und auf dem Stand sein, dass ich wirklich mal wieder gesund in der Zeit sorge. Und das war von dem her dann eine Zeit, wo ich dann auch nicht betrachtet abhaken will. Ich bin gesund geblieben und gut ist.
Das verstehe ich. Aber lass mich an einem Punkt bitte kurz noch nachhaken. Und dann können wir auch das Schalke-Kapitel zumachen. Wenn du Spielpraxis wolltest, warum bist du dann zu einem Verein gewechselt, der so viele gesetzte Innenverteidigungen zu dem Zeitpunkt hatte?
Ich wollte einfach nur weg. Wenn ich so durch die Tür gesackt worden bin.
Gab es nicht so viele andere Angebote?
Zu dem Zeitpunkt war ich vielleicht auch blauäugig und habe gedacht, okay, jetzt gehe ich zu Schalke.
Blauäugig ist auf Schalke nicht ganz gut, wenn es königsblau ist.
Gehe ich zu Schalke, mache Spiele und dann so, mal schauen wir mal. Also an sich war das ein großer Fehler. Aber so ist es halt manchmal so. Ich hätte wahrscheinlich woanders hingehen können, definitiv. Zu Schalke war jetzt im Nachhinein ein Fehler, weil da vieles nicht gestimmt hat und für mich es auch nicht gut angefühlt hat. Aber ich bin gesund geblieben, was nach der Periode, was ich davor erlebt habe, für mich es A und O war und um im Spielrhythmus wieder reinzukommen, was okay geklappt hat. Aber wohlgefühlt habe ich mich da nie.
Gut, es war halt auch ein harter Bruch zum einen, von dem eigentlich immer spielen, wenn man fit ist, zu nicht spielen.
Ja, aber auch eher der große Bruch nach 14, 5 Jahren, Familie zu verlassen. Das ist ein Umfeld, wo du so viel erlebt hast durch deine Jugend, wo du schwere, also Wahnsinnszeiten hattest mit dem Aufstieg, also mit dem persönlichen Aufstieg in deiner Karriere, mit Enttäuschungen, Niederlagen, Freundschaften, die sich entwickelt haben. Der ganze Verein, wo du den ganzen Verein in- und auswendig kennst, die Strukturen auswendig kennst, die das Prozedere einfach kennst, und dann nach 14, 5 Jahren auch noch so der Abschied so ist, das tut einfach weh. Das tut einfach weh sowas und das habe ich nicht so schnell verkraftet. Weil ich einfach mit Herz und Seele dabei bin und ich habe mich so auf den Verein eingelassen und wie gesagt auch durch schwierige Phasen gegangen bin, wo ich abhängig von Ärzten war. Ich habe alles dafür getan, aber wenn halt gewisse Dinge schiefgehen, dann bin ich machtlos dagegen.
Und wenn du jetzt aber sagst, es war irgendwie so ein unschönes Ende für dieses sehr, sehr lange Kapitel in FC Bayern, dann klar, ein Teil des Unmut richtet sich gegen Cando Ancelotti. Ich denke, das ist für jeden nachvollziehbar. Aber geht es dann auch um die Art und Weise, wie du verabschiedet wurdest?
Naja, der Tag, wo ich verabschiedet wurde, war schön für mich, weil ich habe mit Stuttgart 4-1 in München gewonnen.
Aber das kam natürlich erst verzögert.
Aber auch zum richtigen Zeitpunkt. Nach der Zeit, auf Schalke verabschiedet zu werden, da hätte ich mich nicht so gut gefühlt, wie ich mich ein Jahr später gefühlt habe. Ich habe eine Saison gespielt, mit dem VfB Stuttgart eine gute Saison gespielt, zwei Gegentore, war dort eine Führungsperson und habe dann noch in München 4-1 gewonnen. Was? Wo ich wusste, Bayern München will gewinnen, denn die werden an dem Tag die Meisterschale regeln. Ich weiß, wie es funktioniert. Das Spiel wollen die immer gewinnen. Und 4-1 in München zu gewinnen, bin ich mal gespannt, wenn es die nächste Mannschaft wieder macht. Das war so eine Art Genugtuung für mich, um den Abschied besser abzuhaken. Es ging jetzt nicht um den Sieg, sondern einfach um die Sache. Okay, jetzt ist es für mich mit einem schönen Erlebnis die Zeit in München vorbei.
Und wie kam es dann, wenn wir jetzt schon so lange darüber gesprochen haben, dass die Episode Schalke nur eher ein Fehler war, wie kam es dann dazu, dass du dann zur Saison 17, 18, das ist die, von der wir jetzt gerade schon sprechen, eben zu den aufgestiegenen Stuttgartern mit Hannes Wolf gewechselt bist?
Es gab mehrere Optionen. Ich bin schon ein Typ und ein Mensch, der eine gewisse Verbindung zu irgendwas haben muss. Ich kann nicht zu irgendeinem Verein 0815 gehen, wo ich sage, ja, das spiele ich halt da mal. Es war natürlich auch ein Risiko, weil du gehst zu einem Aufsteiger, aber mit einer Riesentradition, mit einem riesen Fanbase, mit einer Historie, in der Bundesliga-Historie auf Platz 5. Also es ist ja ein großer Verein. Wo ich aber dann auch noch meine Geschichte hatte mit zwei Jahren in der Jugend. Mein Vater hat hier trainiert, also es war schon eine Verbindung einfach da. Und die Nähe zur Familie nach eben so einer Phase in meiner Karriere, in meinem Leben, wo ich nicht so gut verdaut hatte, das war mir einfach sehr wichtig. Und dann bin ich dieses Risiko eingegangen, weil ich es auch allen wieder zeigen wollte. Ich bin wieder da, ich kann, mein Körper funktioniert auch für eine ganze Saison, was er auch getan hat. Ich bin dann aber mehr oder weniger ohne Vorbereitung eingestiegen, habe eigentlich diese Saison mehr oder weniger durchgespielt, was für mich einfach auch persönlich wichtig war, um zu sehen, ey, dein Körper funktioniert wieder. Nach all den Strapazen, nach all den Operationen, den Namen, ach, den seelischen Namen, was jetzt in den letzten Jahren passiert ist, ich will sie jedem zeigen. Und das Jahr war sehr erfolgreich für mich, weil, wie gesagt, mit dem Aussteiger auf Platz 7 zu landen, zweitbeste Defensive, dann in München noch zu gewinnen, das waren einfach Höhepunkte oder Erfolge, die schön waren und mir auch gezeigt haben, ok, du bist jetzt wieder da. Und dann, du kannst dir vertrauen, du kannst deinem Körper vertrauen, lass dich nicht von vielen anderen irgendwas einreden, sondern du hast es dir gezeigt.
jetzt ist es auch gut, du musst dieselben Niveau.
Jetzt ist die Seite umgeblättert und du hast eine neue, unbeschriebene, die du beschreiben kannst. Jetzt ist es ja so, dass du beim VfB damals im Jahr 2017 mit 28 Jahren der Erfahrene warst. Also wenn ich mir sonst die Verteidiger angucke, dann sehe ich da Pavard und Baumgart mit 21, Kaminski mit 25. Wie hat denn das deine Rolle verändert?
Ja, ich habe mich schon immer eigentlich, also ich kann schon Verantwortung übernehmen. Auch in meinen Jahren als Bayern habe ich mich so gesehen, natürlich nach außen. Aber ich habe auf dem Platz versucht, immer verantwortlich und lautstark zu sein, weil es einfach ein Innenverteidiger auch, meiner Meinung nach, sein muss, weil er viel, viel die Dinge sieht, weil er das Spiel vor sich hat, weil er die Dinge ordnen kann, weil er Mitspielern helfen kann. Und das habe ich mir natürlich auch zur Aufgabe gemacht, das in Stuttgart zu machen. Ich wusste wirklich nicht, wie viele Junge da sind, aber es waren sehr, sehr viele Junge, unerfahrene Jungs, die zum Teil von der Jugend rauskamen, die noch gar nicht im Männerfußball gespielt oder eingesetzt wurden. Und das war neu für mich. Ich wusste, es wird auf jeden Fall eine Aufgabe für mich, mir das selber zu beweisen, meinen Körper wieder auf Waterman zu bringen, eine Saison durchzuhalten, aber dann auch die Verantwortung zu haben. Du bist beim Aufsteiger, ich weiß nicht, was kommen wird. Du musst Spieler führen, ein junger Trainer, der noch nie Bundesliga trainiert hat. Viele neue Dinge, das habe ich mir angenommen. Zum Glück ist es mir gut gelungen. Klar, es gab noch einen Trainerwechsel, da kam ein erfahrener Trainer rein. Das waren dann alles die richtigen Schritte. Aber für mich selber war das Jahr und eigentlich auch der Erfolg wichtig. Der Erfolg war für mich einfach wichtig. So eine junge Mannschaft zu führen, einen Tabellenplatz zu erreichen, einen Aufsteiger mit gewissen wichtigen Erkenntnissen mit Gegentoren etc. Das war für mich schon wichtig zu sehen. Das war für mich schon ein kleiner Erfolg.
Und ist man da dann automatisch, wenn man als der Ältere in Anführungszeichen kommt, derjenige, der dann die Jungen an die Hand nimmt, und warst du jetzt dann derjenige, der dann Tipps verteilt im Training?
Ja klar, aber das habe ich so angenommen. Das war ja auch ganz klar für mich, dass ich diese Aufgabe annehme und der Aufgabe auch gerecht werden will, Verantwortung zu übernehmen, die Jungen zu führen, weil ich es ja selber so genossen habe und ich profitiert habe davon. Also will ich das gleiche auch weitergeben, weil es den Spielern, in denen ich etwas sehe und die aufmerksam sind und die mir Respekt zahlen, denen kann ich nur helfen und denen kann ich viel beibringen und viel weitergeben.
Wie hast du dann Hannes Wolf erlebt, der dann irgendwann in der Saison freiwillig gegangen ist?
Ja, unerfahren. Schon auch mit einer gewissen Spielphilosophie. Das hat er schon gehabt. Es waren eben viele Dinge, wo ich wusste, dass es nicht so läuft. Im Profifußball, in der Bundesliga wird das so nicht funktionieren.
Wir sind nicht schlecht dargestanden, was meinst du damit?
Er war zu der Zeit ein junger Trainer, der noch nie Bundesliga trainiert hat. Ich habe keine Beispiele, aber in gewissen Situationen muss man als Trainer auch die Ruhe bewahren. Er konnte aber nichts dafür, weil er die Erfahrung noch nicht hatte. Das habe ich ihm auch nicht übel genommen. Ich wusste, ich muss dann eigene Initiative ergreifen, um ihm dann auch etwas abzunehmen oder zu helfen. Woher soll er das wissen?
Eine Initiative auf dem Platz?
Ja, aber auch neben dem Platz, dass er gewisse Umstellungen nicht machen konnte. Es waren eben ein paar Alte dabei und viele, viele Junge. Es war nicht so dazwischen, dass da Spiele waren, die ein paar Jahre Bundesliga schon auf dem Buckel hatten, sondern es waren halt welche, die schon lange in der Bundesliga sind und welche, die ganz frisch dazukommen, die unerfahren sind, die aus der Jugend zum Teil rauskommen, also die natürlich auch erstmal sich entwickeln müssen. Und die Mischung ist natürlich dann und dann noch ein junger Trainer und ein Sportverstand, der auch neu ins Geschäft kommt. Es waren eben viele, viele Leute neu in ihren Positionen, wo aber das Geschäft nicht die große Erfahrung im Geschäft hatte. Und das hat man dann schon gespürt in gewissen Situationen. Und das heißt so, weiß ich jetzt nicht mehr, aber ich kann mich einfach nur daran erinnern, wie ich mich da gefühlt habe, dass man einfach auch ruhig bleiben muss und zum Teil keine Interviews geben muss oder keine Angrifffläche in die Medien geben muss. Weil Stuttgart natürlich dann auch sehr medial präsent ist. Aber manchmal muss man halt auch schlau sein und nicht naiv denken.
Ich kann mich noch erinnern, dass es in der Phase unter Hannes Wolf viele Spiele gab, in der man die erste Halbzeit abwartender gespielt hat. Dann lag man null ans zurück und dann gab es eine überzeugende zweite Halbzeit, in der man es aber nicht mehr geschafft hat, das Ruder herumzuweisen. Das hat für mich als Außenstehenden eher so ausgesehen, als wäre er zu vorsichtig an dieses Projekt Erste Liga rangegangen und hätte vielleicht mehr zu seinen offensiven Überzeugungen stehen sollen, mit denen man ja auch aufgestiegen ist. Hat sich das für dich auch so dargestellt?
Ja, wir haben zum Teil mit vier Innenverteidigungen gespielt. Wir haben ja drei oder fünf Hockeytags gespielt mit vier Innenverteidigungen.
Also ja, es war ein bisschen zu vorsichtig.
Ja, es war halt für mich manchmal nicht so verständlich, weil er sich nicht wirklich entscheiden konnte. Dann waren wieder viele Wechsel, diese Rotation. Das kam ja dann allgemein in Deutschland so ein bisschen in Fahrt. Rotation, ja, aber gewisse Gefüge muss ich halt finden. Es ist einfach so. Das sind dann Abläufe im Spiel. Man kann nicht immer alles austauschen. Man muss ein gewisses Gerüst auf dem Platz haben, das sich dann auch entwickelt, das sich findet. Und darum kann man immer wieder rotieren. Aber ich finde halt, diese Rotation, das ständig Rotieren bringt nur Unruhe rein. Und da gibt es auch keine Hierarchie mehr. Für mich ist Hierarchie schon wichtig. Es soll schon eine Hierarchie in der Mannschaft geben, weil das einfach, glaube ich, auch für Ruhe in der Mannschaft sorgt. Anstatt dann jeder sagen zu können, ich spiele, ich spiele, ich spiele. Ja, aber wenn einer mal einen schlechten Tag hat, dann wird ihm auch wieder das Vertrauen geben. Manche Spieler sind natürlich auch sehr sensibel und man muss auf verschiedene Individualitäten achten. Das war da ja nicht der Fall.
Aber gab es denn keine Hierarchie?
Doch, doch, doch. Aber erst am Schluss. Da wurde dann auch die Serie angefangen. Da gab es dann eine Hierarchie. Wir haben, glaube ich, in elf oder zwölf Spielen mit sehr, sehr ähnlicher Formation gespielt.
Das war dann unter Typhoon Corp. Da gab es nun aber auch viele Spiele. Ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, ob das jetzt nur die Retrospektive ist, aus dem man dann wusste, wie die nächste Saison gestartet ist. Aber da gab es durchaus Spiele, wo der VfB irgendwie das 1 zu 0 gemacht hat. Da hatte gerade auch Mario Gomez eine sehr gute Phase. Auch nach Standard-Situationen gab es da das ein oder andere Tor. Und dann hat man es einfach geschafft, mit einer guten Verteidigung das Spiel über die Zeit zu bringen.
Da wurden kleine Schräubchen gedreht, aber die waren die richtigen Schrauben zu der Zeit. Mehr wäre zu viel gewesen.
Also die Schräubchen waren quasi…
Ja, die derbentifischen Abilitäten, Gerüst darzustellen. Das sind jetzt die Spieler, die müssen es reißen, Vertrauen zu schaffen, wieder auch eine andere Stimmung in der Mannschaft zu schaffen und dann erst mal stabil zu stehen. Wir hatten auch unter Hannes Wolf nicht viele Gegentore. Aber diese Stabilität war dann nochmal mehr vorhanden. Und dass einfach gewisse Tugenden wieder an den Tag gelebt werden, dass wir aus der defensiven Stabilität Chancen kreieren. Aber wichtig ist erst mal, diese Kompaktheit darzustellen, weil damit ist schon viel getan und das hat es uns gezeigt. Nach vorne haben wir dann immer wieder ein Tor gemacht. Wir waren ja die Minimalisten. 1-0, 1-0, 1-0, 0-1, 2-0. Aber wir sind stabil gestanden. Und ein gutes Münchenspiel war dann ein Ausreißer. Aber er hat an die richtigen Schrauben gedreht, er hat vertraut. Und er hat eben den richtigen Spielern auch die Verantwortung gegeben.
Und was hat dann zur nächsten Saison hin gefehlt? War das dann der nächste Schritt, der hätte kommen müssen, dass man sich ein bisschen weniger darauf verlässt, das 1-0 zu machen?
Personalien. Die Mannschaft war homogen, also in der guten Phase. Und zur neuen Saison wurden Personalien verändert, die aber die Mannschaftsstruktur verändert haben, die die Hierarchie verändert haben. Das war nicht gut. Und dafür waren nicht die Trainer, sondern eher die Planer viel verantwortlich, die aber nicht kapiert haben, wie der Erfolg in der Vorseite zustande kommt, welche Charaktere in der Mannschaft wichtig waren für die Phase. Beispiel jetzt Daniel Ginczek, Publikumsliebling, kannte den Verein, steht für den Verein, hat unfassbar viel geackert für das Team, was untergegangen ist. Aber er war wichtig, sehr wichtig, verkauft aus irgendwelchen Gründen. Aber Matthias Zimmermann, Mentalität, wurde verkauft, hat das selber gesagt. Er hat letztes Jahr bei Düsseldorf gespielt. Er kannte den Verein, kam aus einer Verletzung zurück, hat sich zurückgekämpft. Man konnte sich immer auf ihn verlassen. Solche Spieler sind wichtig für die Mannschaft, und die waren weg. Da wurde neu hinzugefügt, wo man vielleicht eher dachte, die steigern das Fußballerisse, die Qualität. Aber für die Mannschaft waren gewisse Eigenschaften nicht mehr vorhanden. Das war nicht gut.
Bei mir im Rasenfunk Royale hat der Journalist Phil Maisel gesagt, was in der Zeit – und wir sprechen ja jetzt über Transfers von Michael Reschke – gefehlt hat. Im Scouting beim VfB wäre ein Scouting nach sozialer Kompetenz, meint der Spieler. Das hört sich ein bisschen so an wie das, was du jetzt erzählst.
Also so sehe ich es und das ist auch absolut meine Meinung, dass eben Transfers getätigt wurden, verkauft wurden oder geholt wurden, die nicht ins Gruppengefüge gepasst haben. Das war nicht gut von vornherein und dann hat es sich auch so gestartet. Dann ein schneller Trainerwechsel, da wurde ja alles…
Kam der für dich zu früh?
Ja, absolut. Man muss auch mal die Ruhe bewahren, wenn es nach sechs Spieltagen… Wir waren jetzt nicht abgeschlagen oder so, aber wir waren jetzt nicht gut gestartet.
Aber ich glaube, in Hannover verloren.
Ja, aber es war… Ich fand es zu früh. Es war nicht mein Gefühl, dass das der richtige Zeitpunkt ist. Dann war für mich sowieso die Entscheidung zum nächsten Trainer völlig unverständlich. Da sind persönliche Dinge passiert, die…
Du redest jetzt von Markus Weinze, den du ja schon auf Schalke kennengelernt hast.
Ja, und damals hatte ich eine ungute Zeit und natürlich war ich gebrannt.
Aber was sind da dann für Dinge passiert, wo du jetzt so deutliche Kritik auch übst? Auf Schalke hattest du keine Spielpraxis, da kamen aber ja verschiedene Sachen zusammen.
Ja, wenn man ein Spiel erholt, dann wird dem natürlich was vorgegaukelt. Und dann fällt das nach gewisser Zeit einfach weg.
War das auf Schalke so? Ich habe in einer Artikel gelesen, dass Schalke sogar gesagt hätte, sie hätten genügend Inverteidiger. Ich glaube, es stand in der Süddeutschen. Und du hättest dann Weinzel angerufen und gesagt, du würdest es trotzdem gerne probieren wollen.
Na ja, so war es jetzt nicht. Er würde mich gerne haben wollen, er braucht meine Passsicherheit, er braucht meine Qualität. Also das waren so die Gespräche. Warum soll ich sonst von Bayern weg? Wenn mich einer nicht haben will, verstehe ich jetzt nicht. Aber da werden halt auch wieder Dinge geschrieben. Ich weiß ja nicht, von wem die Dinge dann auch verbreitet werden. So wie auch das am Schluss, das war nicht korrekt.
Was meinst du jetzt damit?
Ja, auf Schalke, da sie dann gesagt haben, sie würden den Vertrag nicht mit fünf länger machen. War für mich keine Frage, dass ich da bleiben will. Aber das wurde dann, ja man sagt es halt, mit mir wurde da gar nichts abgesprochen. Und das dann einfach zu sagen, so darzustellen, dass sie die Macht über mich hätten, dass sie entschieden haben, sie geben mir keinen einen Vertrag, völlig unsinnig. Hätten sie einfach gesagt, Holger Badstuber und Schalke trennen sich, es war ausgemacht auf fünf Monate erledigt das Thema. Aber so darzustellen…
Warum ist dir das so wichtig? Ist das nicht normal? Ja, weil das mein Link ist.
Das ist einfach was, was ich überhaupt nicht mag, wenn man so falsch ist. Aber du hättest ja die Möglichkeit, das einfach klarzustellen über deine Schmider-Profile. Natürlich, vielleicht zu Recht, ja. Aber es sind einfach Sachen, wo ich sage, solche Personen mit denen will ich nichts zu tun haben. Die sollen mir ins Gesicht sagen, wenn sie mich nicht haben wollen. Wenn sie sagen, pass auf, dann muss ich doch mit klarkommen. Aber irgendwas über die Medien zu verbreiten, damit irgendwas gesagt wird, damit sie irgendwie die Oberhand drüber haben, finde ich nicht korrekt. Das ist etwas, was ich absolut nicht merke im Privaten und auch nicht im Fußball. Im Endeffekt bestrafen sie sich selber. Heidel und Weinsel sind beide weg vom Schalke. Der Erfolg blieb komplett aus. Und mit so einer Mannschaft so etwas nicht hinzubekommen, ist schwer. Wir hatten Max Maier, wir hatten Guretzka, wir hatten Konar Sinac, wir hatten Huntelaar. BD Imst ging übrigens ähnlich wie mir, der jetzt wieder bei Ajax seit Jahren spielt und da eine gewisse Rolle hat. Aber er ist wichtig. Hundertprozentig ist dieser Spieler wichtig. Obwohl er so viel für Schalke geleistet hatte über die Jahre, von diesem Trainer nicht beachtet oder kein Vertrauen geschenkt hat, weil er auch eine Meinung hatte. Es ist immer wieder dasselbe Prozedere, dass gewisse Spieler, die Erfahrungen haben, die unter großen Trainern trainiert haben, die eine Meinung haben, die vielleicht auch mal Gegenstand äußern, laut sind, die werden aussortiert oder einfach gemieden oder ruhig gestellt. Warum? Die wollen nur den Erfolg.
Na gut, aus Sicht der Trainer gibt es ja schon einen Grund. Du hast ja vorhin bei Hannes Wolf zum Beispiel als Beispiel gebracht, dass er in manchen Punkten seine Autorität nicht bewahrt hat vor der Mannschaft. Und ist das nicht genau die Argumentation aus der der Trainer?
Ja, er war nicht autoritätisch. Ich würde sagen, er war halt zum Teil neu in dem Geschäft. Er war zum Teil naiv und unerfahren. Und das hat man halt in gewissen Situationen im Alltag erlebt. Ja, aber das war eben ein junger Trainer oder ist eben ein junger Trainer. Das ist ja auch logisch.
Okay, klar. Aber es ist ja auch klar, dass ein Trainer erstmal nicht Widerrede hören möchte und es eben… Also ich finde es schon nachvollziehbar, ohne dass ich jetzt damit…
Warum zeigt dann der Trainer nicht einfach Stärke und sagt, pass auf, wir erklären das mal unter vier Augen? Was ist deine Sicht der Dinge? Was ist meine Sicht der Dinge? Wir müssen einen Kompromiss finden oder du hast es zu akzeptieren? Du hast es zu akzeptieren, was ich vorgebe, was ich… Ich bin derjenige, der der Entscheidungsträger ist. Ich bin dafür verantwortlich über die ganze Truppe. Warum wird dem dann aus dem Weg gegeben, indem er einfach den Spieler bestraft, obwohl der Spieler einfach Dinge erkennt, Dinge sieht, die falsch laufen bzw. die nicht erfolgsführend sind? Das verstehe ich nicht. Ich kann es einfach von mir aus sagen, ich will ja immer nur das Beste für den Erfolg. Ich will, dass man sich einfach verbessert. Das will ich mit meinen Mitspielern, mit der Mannschaft, mit dem Verein. Aber wenn ich dann halt eine gewisse Schwäche an einem Trainer merke, dann bin ich auch mal gebrankt von den großen Trainern, die ich hatte, weil die einfach eine Autorität hatten. Die hatten klare Vorgaben, die hatten eine Philosophie, die hatten Stil, die hatten Menschlichkeit, die hatten vor allem eines, die waren geradeaus. Und wenn ich merke, dass einer das nicht ist, dann bin ich auch kompliziert.
Also hast du nicht gejubelt, als Markus Prenz jetzt zum VfB kam?
Naja, um nicht zu sagen, ich habe zu Mario Gomez gesagt, das wird ein CSR so. Und so ist dann auch gekommen, weil ich wusste, was da auf uns zukommt.
Woran hat es denn dann gelegen, dass der VfB abgestiegen ist? Also nur der Trainer ist ja nicht immer verantwortlich.
Nein, um Gottes Willen, aber da haben einfach so viele Dinge wieder zusammengespielt. Natürlich, die Mannschaft war nicht homogen, die war keine Einheit. Da haben sich dann einfach die Hierarchie verändert. Ich war auch eine Zeit lang raus, im zweiten halben Jahr war ich achtmal auf der Tribüne. Ein Jahr davor habe ich 27 Spiele gemacht und war schon einer der Führungspersonen. Warum? Dann ist es nicht normal, dass ich dann auf der Tribüne bin. Ich habe mich aber nie dazu geäußert, weil ich nicht mehr Öl ins Feuer gießen wollte. Da nehme ich mich dann auch zurück, aber ich verhalte mich professionell, ich arbeite an mir, keine Ahnung, wenn ich gebraucht werde, bin ich da. Im zweiten Jahr habe ich ja eine Einwechslung und dann halte ich zwei Spiele dann. Wenn es dann drauf ankam, dann haben wir gesagt, der Badstuber muss richten so ungefähr.
Was man ja aber auch als Kompliment verstehen könnte, also klar, gehst du da mit Frust rein, aber war ja noch alles möglich.
Es ist ja auch keine einfache Situation gewesen, ein Jahr so zu erleben.
Quasi von der Tribüne in die Relegation.
Ja, aber das ist ja eine Relegation, ein Spiel, in dem man halt hopp oder top ist. Entweder bist du Ding oder du bist halt weg.
Andererseits hast du ja Champions-League-Finals gespielt.
Ja, aber das ist auch noch mal eine Situation, weil da geht es dann schon auch um… Ja, klar, ich kenne den Druck. Das habe ich dann auch zeigen können. Aber von 0 auf 100 ohne Spielpraxis und dann in so einem Spiel war keine einfache Situation für mich, aber schlussendlich haben wir das nicht erreicht.
Wie wichtig ist dann in so einem Spiel, wie eben der Relegation gegen Union Berlin, vor allem dann im Rückspiel, welche Rolle spielt da noch Taktik? Um was geht es in solchen Spielen?
Ja, da geht es dann vor allem ums Mentale und sich da einfach so reinzubeißen und so zu investieren, mehr zu investieren. Natürlich spielt Taktik immer eine kleine Rolle, aber da hat es definitiv eine kleinere Rolle gespielt, weil wir auch nicht eine Mannschaft waren, die taktisch gesehen klug war, also auch selber. Weil wir, glaube ich, Eigenschaften oder Personalien in einer Mannschaft hatten, die mit denen du nicht viel taktisch vorgeben oder überfordern konntest, taktisch gesehen, oder Horizont einfach begrenzt war. Um viele Vorgaben zu machen, deswegen haben wir es dann auch nicht geschafft. Das wäre zu viel gewesen, wenn Nico Willig seine Philosophie voll reinbrettern wollte innerhalb von vier Wochen. Da war es dann auch richtig von ihm, zu sagen, gewisse Dinge mussten eingehalten werden, aber mehr nicht. In der kurzen Zeit geht es nicht mehr und mehr kann ich auch nicht verlangen.
Das ist einfach so. Wo würdest du im Vergleich zu einem Champions-League-Finale oder einem EM-Halbfinale gegen Italien die Relegation ansiedeln? Das hat sich jetzt gerade für mich angehört, als wäre das die krasseste Drucksituation in deiner Klinik gewesen.
Ja gut, aber entweder bleibst du drin oder steigst ab. Wer will schon absteigen? Klar, ein Champions-League-Finale gewinnt oder verliert, aber du bist trotzdem unter den ersten zwei in Europa. Aber absteigen oder drinbleiben oder absteigen, geht schon um – ich will jetzt nicht sagen Existenz, aber es geht schon auch um Ruf und so weiter.
Und für manche im Verein ja vielleicht schon um den Job. Ja, klar.
Das ist dann schon krass. Um Gehälter, etc. das geht dann schon auch um den Verein, die Mitarbeiter, etc. Klar, da werden dann auch keine Stellen gestrichen, Gehälter gekürzt, auch bei Spielern und so weiter. Das ist einfach so. Aber das ist schon, man will es denen nicht antun.
Den Mitarbeitern?
Ja, klar. Vor allem.
Ja, klar.
Red von den Mitarbeitern. Und aber auch von den Fans, das ist halt krass. Ich hab's, die haben es ja davor schon mal erlebt.
Irgendwie habe ich im Nachhinein das Gefühl, aber das ist jetzt auch fast eine Binse, wenn man auf diese Saison zurückblickt. Aber da lief einfach so viel falsch, dass das fast zwangsläufig – obwohl man immer wieder das Gefühl hatte, der VfB, jetzt springen sie von der Schippe – aber irgendwie im Nachhinein erscheint es fast zwangsläufig, dass es in diesen Abstieg gemündet ist. Würdest du zustimmen? Dann lass uns über angenehmere Dinge sprechen.
Ich hatte ja eine lange Zeit dann so eine Beobachterrolle, weil ich war draußen, ich musste das akzeptieren.
Wobei du natürlich im Training immer noch deinen…
Ja, schon, aber ich konnte nicht aktiv in die Spiele eingreifen, weil ich meistens hier nicht mehr am Kader war. Und ich wusste unter dem Trainer, also wir zwei, geht nicht, Punkt. Das wusste ich. Also so clever bin ich auch, um das dann zu wissen. Die Erfahrung habe ich auf Schalke gemacht, jetzt in Stuttgart.
Ja, das ist jetzt quasi das Signal an alle zukünftigen Entscheidungsträger deiner Mannschaften. Bitte nicht nochmal. Jetzt zweite Liga unter Tim Walter. Ganz anderer Trainer, logischerweise in einer ganz anderen Liga. Und ich habe das Gefühl, sportlich gesehen, dass du auch wieder eine neue Rolle spielst. Die Innenverteidiger unter Tim Walter, die sollen durchaus auch mal andribbeln. Die dürfen, wenn sie nicht unter Druck gesetzt werden, bis an den Sechzehner durchgehen. Was hat sich jetzt verändert zu der Saison?
Erstmal ein kompletter Umbruch von den Personalien in der Mannschaft. Das Trainerteam ist natürlich komplett neu da. Vor zwei Jahren, als ich gekommen bin, sind jetzt noch drei oder vier Spieler da. Der Rest ist komplett ausgetauscht.
Hört sich aber so an, als wäre das was Gutes.
Ich sage jetzt nur die Fakten. Viele junge Spieler mit natürlich gewissen Eigenschaften im spielerischen und im menschlichen, die zu Philosophie passen, die sich entwickeln sollen, in das System rein, in die neue Art zu spielen. Das haben sie sich zur Aufgabe gesetzt beim VfB, als Neustart, als kompletter Neustart, da jetzt was in die Gänge zu bekommen. Und dann mit dem Trainer, der auch seinen Kopf hat für das Spiel Fußball und der das täglich in uns reinhemmert. Für die Jungs ist das natürlich sehr viel, weil sie wahrscheinlich so etwas noch nicht gehabt haben. Für mich ist es jetzt eher einfacher, weil ich es schon erlebt habe, schon kenne, natürlich mit anderen Details und so weiter, aber die Masse der neuen Ideen und der neuen Informationen, die ist enorm. Und für junge Spieler ist das halt was, was sie erst verarbeiten müssen, wo sie Zeit brauchen, aber die Zeit können sie ja haben.
Wie soll denn das Spiel des VfB jetzt aussehen unter dem Ball?
Ja, ich glaube, dass die Außenstehenden und Zuschauer des Alles natürlich sehen, dass es natürlich schon ein offensiver Fußball ist, viel Wahlbesitz, viel Rotation, Risiko. Also Risiko ist definitiv gegeben. Schon gewagt, aber man geht halt aufs Ganze.
Gefällt dir das als Innenverteidiger?
Ja, als Innenverteidiger…
Du hast schon auch viele Eins-gegen-Eins-Rationen jetzt.
Natürlich, das ist für mich jetzt auch wieder neu. Deswegen muss ich… oder habe ich vor allen Dingen am Anfang von der Saison gesagt, ich brauche erstens mal einen sehr guten Fitnessstand, um dieses Spiel dauerhaft durchzuhalten, die Intensität anzunehmen, das ist halt auch das, was neu ist für mich, weil ich bin sehr viel eingebunden, ich muss viele Meter machen, ich muss aber vor allem die Körner haben, um öfters mal dann auch einen langen Sprint zu gehen und einen Eins-gegen-Eins- oder Eins-gegen-Zwei sogar zu bestehen. Das ist schon herausfordernd, weil das ist etwas, wo der Körper schon wirklich alles abverlangt wird und wo ich wirklich auch vom Kopf her immer frisch sein muss, weil das Risiko ist echt gegeben.
Und glaubst du, dass es für die zweite Liga, so wie du sie jetzt erlebt hast, jetzt zu diesem Zeitpunkt der richtige Ansatz? Wird es funktionieren?
Es funktioniert, aber definitiv müssen wir uns ein gewisses Ding noch verbessern. Wir sind jetzt ein Viertel von der Saison gespielt, wir sind dabei, unseren Weg zu gehen. Details müssen wir definitiv noch verbessern, das weiß ich, das weiß der Trainer, das wissen wir. Aber an sich ist der Stil, glaube ich, der kommt uns gelegen und der kommt auch für die, oder der passt zu den Spielern, die jetzt auch neu dazugekommen sind und dabei haben wir auch Spaß, das auszuüben. Diesen Stil und dieses Ballbesitz und diese Rotation und diesen Spaß auch mit reinzubekommen, das taugt uns und das ist etwas, wo wir uns auch sehen und so dominieren wir die Gegner. Aber dennoch müssen wir das Risiko so gering wie möglich halten, dass wir eben nicht ins offene Feuer laufen.
Und wenn du Spaß ansprichst, machst du Spaß anzutribben als Innenverteidiger?
Ich habe gerne den Ball als Innenverteidiger. Sicherlich sind auch für mich neue Wege da, die erstmal automatisiert werden müssen.
Nach all den Trainern, nach all den Spielen immer noch neue Wege.
Ja, aber das ist halt das. Neuer Trainer, neue Sitten, neue Ideen. Und er ist definitiv ein Trainer davon. Und wie gesagt, klar gelte ich jetzt als älterer Spieler, aber auch dazulernen kann man immer. Und das nehme ich auch immer so an. Wichtig ist für mich einfach nur, dass ich wirklich auch – und da kenne ich mich auch – dass ich mich einfach körperlich gut fühle, dass ich mich darauf vorbereite. Und da kann ich jetzt noch an einzelnen Schrauben drehen, um dass ich dieses Spiel einfach auch noch mehr verfeinere und einfach seine Idee des Spieles des Innenverteidigers auch perfektionieren kann.
Gibt es für dich Zweifel am Ausstieg? Bist du fest davon überzeugt?
Absolut nicht. Es gibt eine gewisse Ruhe im Team, im Verein und da gibt es für mich keine Zweifel.
Und kann man dann mit dem Spielstil auch in der ersten Liga so weiterspielen, dein Erfangler?
Ja, das ist dann eine andere Frage. Wie gesagt, ich sage, wir müssen uns definitiv noch verbessern in einigen Dingen, aber das ist auch einfach die Entwicklung der Mannschaft. Man entwickelt sich mit der Zeit zusammen, man verändert die Kleinigkeiten oder die Dinge, wo man nicht gut macht, wo man die Chancen zulässt, wo man die Chancen des Gegners eigentlich kreiert. Das muss man halt offen und ehrlich auch erläutern und aufzeigen und analysieren. Und dann müssen wir es halt auch auf dem Platz zeigen, dass uns diese Einladungen nicht passieren. Sonst wird es schwer, dann gegen bessere Qualität durchzuhalten.
Gut, eins nach dem anderen. Ich könnte noch sehr lange mit dir weitersprechen, aber so langsam… Ja, aber du hast eine gute Ausdauer, du bist topfit. Herzlich willkommen in der Podcast-Welt, das ist mein Leben. Du hast gespielt Gegenspieler wie Lewandowski, Götze, Eto, Maicon, Rooney, Milito, Del Piero, Trezeguet, Totti, Wesley Snyder, Zanetti, Dzeko, Aguero, Di Maria, Benzema, Cristiano Ronaldo, Hamche, Cavani, Carresma, Robinho, Neymar, Cevchenko, Giroud van Persie, Balotelli, Higuain, Messi, Ibrahimovic. Gegen wen war es am schwierigsten? Bei wem hast du jetzt gezuckt, als ich den Namen gesagt habe?
Eto war für mich schwierig zu spielen.
Warum?
Weil er wendig ist, weil er schnellig ist, weil er unberechenbar ist. Für mich waren größere Spieler nicht so gefährlich, aber gerade so wendige Spieler, schnelle Spieler, unberechenbare Spieler.
Aber Eto ist doch auch ein ganz schöner Kampfer, oder?
Nein, nein, nein, er ist stark, aber er ist sehr beweglich und auch unberechenbar, was macht er, geht er tief, kommt er entgegen, welche Seite geht er, das ist schon sehr, sehr gut gewesen.
Noch vor Messi und Cristiano Ronaldo?
Ja, mit Ronaldo kam ich nie so in Berührung, weil er meistens links war und ich bin linker Endverteidiger und da kommt man nicht so oft zusammen. Messi holt sich die Bälle auch mal hinten und kommt dann. Aber als Stürmer sehe ich auch ein Tor, auch Cavani sind gute Stürmer. Die Stürmer sind einfach brandgefährlich und unberechenbar zum Teil.
Wenn du für den A-Jugendspieler Badstuber ein Training organisieren durftest, was hättest du ihm gerne mit Übungen auf den Weg gegeben?
Ja, da will ich nicht zu sehr ins Detail gehen, den Spieler seine Freiheiten lassen, aber gewisse Hinweise geben, wo er den Ball nicht verlieren darf, ihm auch deutlich und klar erzählen, was er verbessern muss, um wirklich ein Guter zu werden.
Was war denn das, was du am Anfang noch verbessern musstest, um noch besser zu werden?
Ja, Heimer Geller hat mich immer ans Kopfballbindel geschickt, immer wieder ans Kopfballbindel.
Wen hat er nicht dahingeschickt?
Ja, aber vor allem…
Seit meiner eigenen Mutter.
Dann gab es ja auch ein paar Spiele, das habe ich von Anfang an eigentlich drin gehabt, aber dann auch die Schnelligkeit, die man haben muss. Aber das ist auch etwas, was ich jetzt wieder verbessern kann. Ich glaube einfach, dass man so viel individuell noch arbeiten kann, aber da muss man erstmal auf dem Stand sein, um danach eins drauf zu packen. Man muss die Grundbasis haben, dann kann man einen weiteren Schritt machen. Das fühle ich jetzt momentan zum Beispiel, da habe ich das eigentlich drin und jetzt kann ich individueller werden. Gerade, weil ich merke, durch den Spielstil jetzt muss ich öfters eins gegen eins. Ich muss die Körner aber auch in der 80. Minute haben, um noch einen Sprint anzusehen. Das kann man sich erarbeiten, das kannte ich jetzt auch noch nicht so, aber jetzt so nach und nach überlegt man sich halt Dinge, wo man noch Details verändern kann und da muss ich halt individuell ran und das kann ich mir auch erarbeiten. Für mich steht das außer Frage, aber alles kommt Step-by-Step, aber wie gesagt zu dem 19-jährigen Badstuber hätte ich gesagt, da musst du noch arbeiten, rechter Fuß arbeiten und einfach zuhören, lernen, in welchen Phasen es einfach wichtig ist, auch die Ruhe zu bewahren.
Zuhören, lernen bringt uns auch zur nächsten Frage. Welcher deiner Trainer war für dich der wichtigste? Ich lehne mich mal aus dem Fenster und Markus Weins hier nicht.
Es hat einfach nicht gepasst. Wichtigste – Louis van Gaal bleibt für mich immer einer der wichtigsten. Weil er mich einfach reingeschwissen hat. Jupp Heynckes war ein ganz toller Trainer, ein ganz toller Mensch. Pep hat von ihm so viel gelernt, fein Horizont zu erweitern. Das waren die drei, die für mich einfach über allem stehen.
Und abschließende Frage – sehen wir dich noch mal auf internationaler Bühne?
Ich sage mal so – warum nicht? Ich traue es mir auf jeden Fall zu. Aber das hört sich jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen gewagt an und selbstbewusst an. Aber so ist es. Im Fußball kann immer alles so schnell gehen. Keine Ahnung, vor zwei Jahren wären wir fast nur in den UEFA Cup gekommen mit dem VfB. Jetzt ist eben gerade die Situation so. Ich habe immer um mich geglaubt. Ich werde auch weiter an mich glauben. Manche kommen noch mal in ihrem hohen Fußballalter. Ja, deswegen. Aber das wird ja heutzutage so betitelt, dass 30 ja schon alt ist. Ich fühle mich eigentlich gerade so gut. Ich kenne meinen Körper. Ich habe Erfahrung. Ich weiß, was ich brauche jetzt auch, wo ich mich noch verbessern kann. Das weißt du ja mit 20 nicht so genau von dir aus. Aber ich weiß es und ich weiß, dass ich mir das erarbeiten kann. Von dem her habe ich noch, glaube ich, ein paar Jahre vor mir, um mal zu schauen, wo die Reise hingeht und wie hoch es noch reicht. Aber es besteht mir da kein Limit, sondern ich will mich jeden Tag verbessern. Und wenn ich daran glaube, dann weiß ich auch aus Erfahrung, dann kann vieles passieren.
Holger, ich danke dir ganz, ganz herzlich, dass du dir so viel Zeit genommen hast. Das ist wirklich außergewöhnlich, ich hoffe, es hat dir Spaß gemacht. Du kannst ja zur Vorbereitung auf die 1. Liga die Schlusskonferenz hören. Das ist unser Erstliga-Format und auf die internationalen Spiele kannst du dich mit den internationalen Kurzpässen vorbereiten. Der Rasenfunk ist, es gibt so viel zu hören.
Ich höre das gerne. Und wie gesagt, Fußball ist ein sehr großer Teil in meinem Leben. Und ich werde mich immer damit beschäftigen, immer gerne zuhören und aufsaugen und mitnehmen, was geht.
Kommst du denn mal als Trainer wieder ins Tribünengespräch, könntest du das sagen?
Das wollte ich gerade sagen, vielleicht später irgendwie weitergeben. In welcher Form, kann ich nicht sagen, aber ich will dem Fußball so lange wie möglich irgendwie treu bleiben und irgendwie in irgendeiner Form das weitergeben, was ich erfahren durfte. Ich durfte viele Facetten kennenlernen und das will ich weitergeben, weil ich das auch selber erfahren durfte und das hat mich zu dem gemacht, der ich heute bin. Von dem her sauge ich weiterhin alles auf und der Fußball verändert sich, ich verändere mich. Mal schauen, wo wir in ein paar Jahren sind. In welcher Funktion, keine Ahnung.
Stark. Ich wünsche dir sehr, dass du mal Bundestrainer wirst. Dann kann ich nicht mehr sagen, ich hatte mal einen Bundestrainer. Danke dir Holger für deine Zeit.
Danke auch und hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht.
Das war das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch. Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Punkthäuser.